let me ask you a question
the church is brought to you by
on it.com go to on it for the best
supplements in the business you
understand me go to honor.com
pick a supplement half a brain new mood
shroom tech you like it
press in church get 10 off delivered to
your house number two you ever go to
your dad's house he's mowing along with
his little [ __ ] shorts on his little
[ __ ] [ __ ] slippers
and you ask yourself how long has he
been out here what is he didn't even
take a shower his ass all [ __ ] up
and you say to yourself how bad does my
dad's [ __ ] stink right now
that you'll never have that question
again you know why because father's day
is coming
and hello tushie is there for you the
bidet is back go to hellotushy.com
and take a look at all the fine bidets
you understand me if you like one go to
the box and press in church boom
hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com
church that's the answer to your dad's
[ __ ] father's day is coming
number two are you hiring do you know
where to even post your job to find the
best candidates it's over go to zip
recruiter you know why it's been used by
businesses of all sizes to find the most
qualified
job applicants and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right free just go to
ziprecruiter.com
church again
ziprecruiter.com
church and the church
wants to welcome
one of the best up-and-coming
clothing companies out there you
understand me because looking good
doesn't need to cost you a fortune five
four club is the revolutionary way
for men to shop right now
go to five four club dot com
enter promo code joey and they'll give
you 50 off your first month's package
plus a free player sunglasses you
understand me your future is bright
you got to wear shades that's 50 off
your first package at 5'4 spelled five
four f i v e
f o u r club dot com
promo code joey
hit it lee
oh [ __ ]
may 31st you bad [ __ ]
iron maiden to get this party started
what
uncle joey
celia baja
here we go
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
break out the [ __ ] syringes it's over
meet me in seattle we're going deep
tonight
all right child
here we go
wash that monkey
the church of what's happened now
welcome
welcome to podcastville you bad
[ __ ] uncle joey here you're
safe you're warm
everything's beautiful
lisa you're giggling up a storm i don't
know if i'm safe you've always saved
[ __ ] uncle joey's here and my
guest tonight is the beautiful celia
baja
from littlemommies.com
little mama's mommies whatever the [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying it depends what
time of the day it is
if it's at night you ain't got me but
maybe two in the afternoon what who
gives a [ __ ] do you mind coffee breath
anyway what's happening
nothing good to have you on the show get
close here so we can hear you beautiful
thank you for having me new york
[ __ ] yeah
it's not that bad what's up with you
lisa over there looking like [ __ ] uh
like tiger woods headshot look at your
eyes all [ __ ] up i feel like tiger
woods headshot right now i don't know
you you always say like you have these
different i don't know anything about
weed so you have all these black hairs
and red hairs
you're i don't know what you're putting
in in that bong
but i like it it's craziness you need to
know who cares i can give it a name i
can make a make-believe i
i have this i have carrot 28.
i have you know irby and gold i can make
any [ __ ] name he gives you the no
name anyway
yeah i don't i don't need to know the
name i just like i feel like the other
ones might be tested in the lab and
these ones he's getting from someone
who's like growing them in some secret
solution
i mean i'm only hung out with you guys
for a little bit but i think you like
you actually are the lab yeah pretty
much i could tell wheel of that i don't
make him do nothing i don't do i do
everything he does and double he knows
that this day yeah no i'm not
complaining i'm just saying like i don't
know how you do that i don't know how
your lungs have that capacity it is
impressive because
when i moved to colorado
when i was 19
and i started doing bong hits up there
and that transition period you have that
period where your lungs uh
they have a word for it why george why
you go up there explode no no no no
what's what's that thing that george
mazdawa went to denver accommodate you
acclimate your lungs so okay it makes
your lungs taking more oxygen
so because i was growing up there and
doing bongos at that time up there my
lungs always got a little bigger plus
i've been smoking for 30 years it's not
fair i tell people all the time
i'm not a drinker not because i'm an
alcohol like a
i'm a program or a friend of john's or
something i just enjoyed marijuana
better and the people i like when we
were 15
16.
let's say tonight tonight you called me
and said joey what are you doing ty i
don't know what are you gonna do celia i
don't know my dad's going out tonight my
mom's working
invite lee over invite my boyfriend and
i'll get a girl to come over
that's what six of us mm-hmm all right
so
what do you want to do say that you
would go well
i'll tell you what i'll do i got a 25
bag
you usually get 27 joints i'll give it
to you guys for 20. just chip in give me
the money when you get here that means
i'm coming to your house
and we're going to roll up every 20 that
bag
when i was 16
and we would smoke them all we would
listen to music out my friend the willow
shed
and we will not go home until every
joint was gone
it was one after the other after and god
forbid somebody didn't show up with weed
and go put that away
and we look at each other like oh [ __ ]
that means we're gonna have weed for
tomorrow
like if somebody showed up with a bag of
weed then we go okay
now there's four of us so we each take
the joint home
and we you know say instead of [ __ ]
sitting like i mean we would die hard
we would sit there till every [ __ ]
joint was gone so i always want people
to understand that that
it's not fair i've been smoking before
the big bang [ __ ] theory i'm an old
man
no how long how old were you when you
started smoking 14 14. yeah where did
you start smoking new york city no in
connecticut westport connecticut what
made you smoke at 14. a boy of course
did you ever at the time of smoking did
you dream that you were gonna smoke
no definitely never no no no
me neither no because my parents were
you know i got fed all the
you know war on drugs and dare and all
that and that was a gateway you know no
way how did you feel about alcohol at
that time
uh i didn't drink i didn't drink most of
high school to be fair i i was i
can't believe i'm gonna admit this but
whatever well i was a student educator
in my high school which meant that i
like signed on and said that i was gonna
help educate you know younger classes by
you know about drugs and alcohol and
their effects and i took like a pledge
that i wouldn't drink or do drugs
i held to one of those now when you
smoked at 14 how long do you went back
to smoking at
uh well i started smoking pie at 14. i
smoked all through high school and
college really yeah i mean i always i
definitely was like so while you were a
student moderator you were sneaking off
yeah i was i still smoked pot when i was
a student how did you smoke with people
well you keep it under a hand no i
smoked my friends that i would smoke
when people go look where i'm getting
high with the student moderator no
see thank god
because you know what at least one of
them was also a student educator so we
had like hit it from all the other ones
like we're not really doing that so by
this time what what years were this for
high school uh that was early 90s for me
so early 90s they already had like high
levels i graduated early 90s they
already had high level drug programs oh
yeah
yeah i mean that that rolled out in the
80s the the dare and all that came out
when i was but they never
the only contact i had with cops
about drugs were
in the first grade in new york city
i barely knew english
i signed my mom's put me i don't know
where the [ __ ] i went to kindergarten i
don't think she put me in kindergarten
she just took me to the bar with her
you know it was the easiest way she
didn't trust no [ __ ] kindergarten she
was an immigrant mom
so
uh my dad had died that was all she had
i doubt she put me i don't remember i
remember everything
and i can't yeah i think i probably did
i think i did go to
yes i did why am i lying to people i
don't really go on a ps166
and then like
what the [ __ ] are we talking about oh
so in the first grade they thank you
they take you over to whatever precinct
you belong to and i don't remember the
name i could give it a phony number some
people gonna get pissed off at me
and they took you in in those days they
let you shoot a 22
they fingerprinted you what
they fingerprinted in kindergarten
in the first grade
in the first grade they let you shoot at
22 and then they gave you the bullet
to take home
they gave you the target
different times differently yeah yeah
what
like
i can't even imagine my mom if my mom
found out i shot a gun at six they gave
me the target they gave you a little gun
they gave you
a badge they gave you
you had a signed paper i don't think i
was even allowed to light my [ __ ]
menorah by myself when i was in first
grade you signed something and you were
like a junior cop
holy crap we're gonna obey precincts
orders and [ __ ] and i bought into it
for a few weeks i would see the cop
walking the beat now i don't know if you
should notice
but i'm a junior detective
and i'm on the beat too you know what
i'm saying he would look at me like get
the [ __ ] out of here okay you [ __ ]
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here junior
detective
but they also showed you drugs
they showed you
marijuana
they showed you
i don't remember what i was thinking at
that time like glue
or pcp or something like that and i went
home and i told my mom
and i could see my mom i got look on her
face and like two days later my mom goes
come here come in the kitchen
and she had the babysitter with her she
goes gonna make her monkeys and sit down
and she just started taking weed out she
goes this is marijuana
she goes you know what this is this is
alcohol
and you know what it does to you because
you stole a bottle of wine and got
[ __ ] up
and that's why you don't drink no more
but you know what it is now so this is
marijuana she showed me cocaine wow
and i didn't know what the [ __ ] it was
even i was like she goes if anybody
tries to give me this on the street
tell them to go [ __ ] themselves and
stuff and that was it
that was it we never just really
discussed it as i was older i knew the
drug lingo
but i would make believe like i didn't
know what she was talking about but i
always knew and then when i would go to
my cousin's homes and [ __ ] like that
their parents weren't involved in it but
the kids didn't know
like all drugs are just weed uh
my mom was involved in bookmaking she
had the bar the bar was to cover
the restaurant was the cover
she was partners in the dry cleaner at
the bronx that was another cover
but the main thing was the gambling
the secondary i was at a bar so people
did drugs at the bar i saw people with
white
rings and yellows and i would sit there
and scratch my head the long finger
no there was no this is the sad this is
the early 70s these people didn't want
nobody to know in those days it was
aluminum foil
and a matchbook
and then even grind it up
they would take the fingers and take the
coke rocks and put them in their nose
and i would wake up in the mornings
and in those days that's when the
all-nighters would start
so i would get up in the morning and it
didn't smell like eggs it would smell
like [ __ ]
a pig and black beans and rice and yucca
and i would run the kitchen there'd be
16 people in my house with sp cuban
music on
and everybody's dancing and there's a
[ __ ] thing and nobody's eating
nobody's eating they're all sneaking
into the kitchen and i would hear
and i [ __ ] knew you know what i'm
saying like i would say oh and then my
mom would go look what i made for you no
my mom would do a couple bumps and get
confused too i'm hungry anybody want to
eat oh yeah we all want to eat two hours
later when the meal is done nobody can
eat because they're all [ __ ] jazzed
up
so i i i
put it together at a young age yeah did
i like it no not at all did it deter me
from it
for a long [ __ ] time because why
because you didn't like how they acted i
didn't like the whole [ __ ] thing i
didn't like the whole thing now in the
70s gotta remember
if you were product of the 70s
if you watched television on nine out of
ten shows
let's pretend i was five or six and i
watched the courtship of eddie's father
i watched uh
room 222
i watched uh i don't know when the
waltons came i think the waltons came
out a couple years later yeah but any of
those tv shows 80 percent of those tv
shows
always involved alcohol if you i'll put
on
shows right now on youtube that i've
watched recently
and there's a show called uh on the
family it's a it's a family show it's a
bastion cabin [ __ ] and buffy
and the pilot
he [ __ ] walks in
takes a bottle with no label on it
whatever substance it's brown right so
it could be white rye whiskey bourbon
scotch it could be a bunch of different
things right rum
and they would pour a glass and if you
came over i go celia how are you and i
would never in the 70s
it wasn't even thought of of me to go
celia
no i would pour and give it to you right
and you would go okay and you drink it
in the 70s because duis weren't very
prevalent then
they weren't duis didn't get prevalently
until about 1980. well they were i just
don't think anyone got it right nobody
[ __ ] got this [ __ ] yeah
60 of duis
when i was growing up i would hear it
people go i was [ __ ] up last night i
got pulled up what happened
the cop got in my car and i got in the
cop car
and the other cop drove my car and they
dropped me off in front of my house like
[ __ ] like that no way there was [ __ ]
like that yeah
it wasn't well they would fall
yeah they were following
driving 80 81 was when it started really
weird i saw that accident when i was a
child at 81. i was in an asset new years
and i saw a car break in half went into
a [ __ ] pole
and the people yelling i remember the
girl yelling the guy was dead dead as
disco the chick was yelling and i went
home when i go well i learned the lesson
i'll never [ __ ] drink and drive right
and i remember friends over the years
i had a friend that went home
got horny in the middle of the night
got in his car he was on quaaludes he
went into the city got him uh
got a [ __ ] blow job from a hooker
while he was getting his dick sucked
they got a gun to his head they took his
money it was a scam
they took his money he was pissed off
because he was almost ready to come i
mean when he told me the story the next
day
and i went 19 and he tells me this story
he goes i was ready to [ __ ] nut him
out
and this [ __ ] yam puts a gun to my
head and [ __ ]
threatens to take my money they were in
on it together she was giggling
he goes i just wanted to come he goes i
was going back home to get my atm card
to get more money but he goes i was
hitting boulevard east he hit three cars
like i've had a couple friends
in the early 80s in fact one of the kids
that was a bad night right there oh my
god one of the kids that listens to this
show
uh
his brother when we were going in high
school he had a reputation of never
talking like if if before he picked you
up at night sailing getting the car
[ __ ] what's going on how are you
doing celia you want to do a package
tonight and you're like no i just want
to [ __ ] that
lee what are you doing he'd start
busting your balls and the whole way up
he'd be torturing you you know celia
we're getting [ __ ] up tonight i got
this [ __ ] that killed whatever and then
they get up to corki's bar to get a
package
this guy would do two bumps
and he wouldn't say a word the rest
and people go what the [ __ ] you wouldn't
shut the [ __ ] up on the but this was
after about two or three years of doing
blow in the early 80s he stopped
shutting up like by the mid-80s he
wouldn't say a [ __ ] word anymore
and one night like in 84 maybe 83 he got
a dui he didn't get a dua he crashed the
car and they brought him in and called
his dad
yeah and just to say your son's here he
crashed the car
come pick him up he's been drinking like
that's what it was like yeah
my friend's dad goes down there with the
kid timmy who listens to the show
marblehead and they asked and my
friend's a a heavy-duty guy's dad and he
goes uh where's my son he's right there
he was officer
how was his behavior tonight
and he said the cop looked them straight
in the face and he goes your son didn't
make a peep
so timmy the old man didn't know that he
was high but timmy no he was high
because he didn't make a [ __ ] pain
make a peep
so it's well for him but that's how it
was for people listening to the show who
were young that's how it was if you were
cool
if you went on listen if you got drunk
and went into a [ __ ] tree in those
days
okay
and they would come and there was
alcohol in your car
they would tow your car they would you
know they wouldn't there was no
consequence but i think that there was a
there was a something happened in one of
the states
it was mad
mother's against drunk driving a girl
died
because moms can change [ __ ] and a few
moms got together and they became a huge
movement yeah
her daughter died and the person that
started it her daughter died in a car
accident i will never forget seeing like
the lifetime movie of this and being
like i will never drink drink and drive
um and yeah she died and it was a hit
and run uh drunk driving accident and
that mom tracked down who it was and
then
basically lobbied and got all these moms
together and created mad is what it's
called mothers against drunk driving
still exists and no no no no it became
like this huge movement this huge
coalition they they got that law on the
books for driving drunk driving it's
crazy because when i go to the store at
night
two nights a week i go to the comedy
store and i go take laurel
canyon and i gotta be honest with you i
on the way home i drive so defenseless
so
you know
canyon defensive defensive yeah you're
right defensive
it's [ __ ] crazy especially coming up
the hill
i am
alert as [ __ ] watching those cars oh
yeah i don't play games i don't like
driving that in the nightmare no and i'm
stupid i get home and i go that's the
last time i'm driving little canyon yeah
then a week later i make the left right
there instead of driving him deep down
and going into hollywood by the 101 cafe
there or something no i [ __ ]
shoot up laurel kane and i'm always
thinking one of these nights some drunk
guy is going to come from the valley get
[ __ ] heroin
he's going to be coming down this
[ __ ] hell he's going to lose control
and i'm going to be coming up like an
[ __ ] listen
and i'm going to get hit [ __ ] head on
real specific
yeah that's that's how it happens
you know people get ice like that don't
get ice because
they're speed racing they're they're at
a light
they're driving minding their business
having a conversation or saying you look
up and there's a car coming at you
you know there's a [ __ ] car coming at
you you know what what do you do
you have to be prepared for that night
you're not drinking
you know people come up to me at the
comedy store at night and they come up
to me hey you want to get high
i gotta tell you something i've already
smoked all [ __ ] day by the time eight
o'clock comes yeah by the time the clock
comes there ain't nothing left i could
smoke i need to like i'm all right
already look at me i'm fine i'm tip top
my goo i'm fine you saw me chocolate you
saw me eat stars i don't know it lasts
for 20 30 minutes so i went at night
tip-top you know
in california i feel like i have a
privilege i have this thing in my car
which means [ __ ]
i have a car in my wallet which means
[ __ ]
if the cops pull me off like if i get
pulled over with two pounds of weed in
my trunk this legality card that
everybody in the country is like oh i
could love to get one of those
does [ __ ] well to be fair it does it
doesn't legalize you having two pounds
of weight whatever if the cop wants to
take me in he's going to take me in
because i'm being an [ __ ] right
so i have a privilege the same privilege
you have the same privilege he has
when we're in here you want to do 20
bucks and say that i don't give a [ __ ]
things get [ __ ] up
things get [ __ ] up celia i'll put you
in an uber
and we're all happy
you know what for us to get in the car
right now to go to hollywood and spark
two joints in the car
as much as i smoke pot as much as i'm a
fellonious [ __ ] go in my car
there's never weed in my car i have i
have joints in there to give away the
people yeah like the door guys at the
store
if the weed store gives me like good
perennial joints i give those to the
[ __ ] lock guys they jump up and down
for that weed that's awesome
so but i i don't have weed in my car to
smoke
i'm never sparking my car and in the
back of my mind they give you a [ __ ]
privilege
i agree why are we taking advantage of
were you walking up and down the street
like cheech and chung with smoke coming
out of your [ __ ] car like who gives a
[ __ ] you know i would smoke the vapors
on the plane
let's face it
how high were those vapors really
getting me not really that high
so why am i going to have a felony to
prove what that i'm joking
i don't i have a vapor pen
in the sleep apnea machine when i travel
but yeah it's just in case i get stuck
in an airport for six hours or more but
let me tell you something
i get juiced up oh
edibles i'm going to long island june
23rd and 24th and it's my favorite
flight in the world this is the flight
of death
i started writing music down today so i
can put it on my ipod this is the jet
blue one that you like in the pod
no no no no no because i heard you talk
about that
i got a [ __ ]
one-way shoot down i had an old plane
ticket i had to use my july 26 bingo i'm
a virgin
i took the [ __ ]
the thing let me tell you what i saw
today lee you're not going to believe
what i saw and you're going to say joe
you're lying to me but just to educate
the people at home
when you fly because i tell you all the
time lee when i tell you virgin when i
tell you a book a flight on virgin right
do i pay to get first class no sir what
do i tell you to get you tell me to get
the uh well it's not it's not
cabin it's main cabin main cabin select
okay
i [ __ ] came up with a flight today
people just so you know for people who
don't travel
kiss yourself go
i don't travel because it's it they [ __ ]
you in the ass three times okay
they [ __ ] you and i saw something today
that they're [ __ ] me
almost made me call legally look at
these [ __ ] it was like a bad
line you know what i'm saying you ever
look at a line you're going to gamble
the
new england's at home giving
three points to the team who was over 19
last year what the [ __ ] who's not
playing brady ain't showing up what
league it was the same thing you ready
there's a flight that goes out of lax
same flight one flight
i think it leaves at 1 30 in the
afternoon against the lax uh kennedy at
11 something like this
that flight had first class
for 9
69
and main cabinet select was
ninety nine dollars
that's how hot main cabin selected oh my
god but the word got out and people
started making it you can't get a seat
on main cabin you know why because you
could always opt to first class six
hours before the flight you just gotta
wait like if your flight's at six am you
gotta wake up like
[ __ ] like a dunce in the middle of
the night and call and be the first one
to call six hours and usually i swear to
god celia
sweat in my mother's grave i think
there's only been one time i haven't got
it
like if you get main cabin select you
got first class you you call them and go
i wanna take for a buck and a quarter
so you can't lose main cabin select is
the level up from [ __ ] the rest of
the [ __ ] animals
all right
the seats a little bigger
all right they got a screen and you
could get the waitress to come to you
the waitress oh yeah whatever you want
to call it you press it
order with this [ __ ] you give the you
stop your movie you press pause in the
movie
you go hold on one second you press
pause on the movie you flip the even me
the [ __ ] can do it you flip the screen
over
you say food you've got to make sure you
get all the good [ __ ] early so if you
see something you want on a virgin get
it early
because the thing that sells
everything's everything goes except the
korean chicken sandwich let me tell you
something you might as well eat
somebody's foot
if you're gonna eat a korean chicken
sandwich on virgin airlines you might as
well look at that [ __ ] this guy that
snuck in from whatever country he did
with dry oh god grab his foot and
[ __ ] bite it it's the same difference
the korean chicken even i broke down and
got it one time one of those long
flights just to see what it was like oh
god why did you do that oh god because
you got your stone thousand animals
before no no because when you're gonna
get on the [ __ ] plane okay oh i don't
like it six hour flights you gotta be
prepared you gotta eat a good breakfast
before you're gonna take an aspirin for
your heart to open up you gotta drink
water on the plane so you don't be
honest i don't think i've ever taken an
aspirin before i got enough this is
you never ran with uncle joey
you run one uncle joey you got a baby
aspirin at the gate that's how i roll
you never mean baby because it don't
matter would you you know what i'm
saying you're gonna go eat shitty food
anyway in an hour so it doesn't matter
you probably got a [ __ ] subway
sandwich on your knapsack or something
like that
so yeah that's the [ __ ] difference
you you put a little heart okay and you
get water you don't need to be a [ __ ]
savage on a plane but you do need to get
a little high in deviates no you don't
if you want to eat a viking and that's
up to you you do have to get a little
higher
xanax and get a red wine in here let me
tell you something a five and a half
hour flight i know these people on this
ship that listen to this you guys travel
internationally god bless you tell
[ __ ] lee
that you [ __ ] international
flyers you guys live on xanax all right
the people who fly across the world
they live on that experience they can't
take it they can't take it but why would
they want to use edibles that'd be
better because it's tough to get through
the dog
if you don't want to kill the dog can
you imagine you're [ __ ] walking the
dog sniffs you a can of cookies and all
of a sudden you look back and you're
like pull them over what happened the
dogs died and the dogs are laying there
with their legs up in the air they're
foaming from the mouth
so you can't they can't smell it in the
gummies
[Music]
really yeah when you up in the back you
can tell when you [ __ ] when you uh
go international they got the heavy duty
i watched that show on [ __ ]
you know i went right to mexico from
here not that they cared with my vape
pen and nobody nobody gave it no a vape
pen is like i said this is a day care if
somebody if you if you get caught
smoking on the plane then they take it
off and they do the whole thing but nah
they're not to [ __ ] say nothing to
you for this well because yeah because
it looks like the the tobacco one right
or the whatever the normal one is i
don't know then i had it broken down in
the case it comes in and then you know
just went through nobody stopped me
it's so we you and i were discussing the
reason why i know celia is because she
knows my wife from yoga mm-hmm
so we all went to coffee one day and we
were talking to them
i i wanted to tell sally and my wife's a
sweetheart but she's as straight as an
arrow terry is very straight yeah she's
a stranger i have no idea that you i've
known terry now for what almost uh two
and a half years i think had no idea
that was your wife like i can't drop a
lot of knowledge on terry because
she would just look at me like what the
[ __ ] yeah when she called me and she was
like celia do you know who my husband is
because i think maybe you know you want
to be on a show i was like what why
who's your husband and then she told me
i was like yeah i don't see that at all
but then when i saw you guys together
you guys actually make complete sense
but uh yeah you're she's like this super
yogi flexible
like earthy
t
yeah go bagoba to go to bed
meanwhile i'm popping 2 000 milligrams
except she's [ __ ] hilarious i have to
say she's like my favorite person to
stand next to in yoga because she just
makes fun of all the poses
my wife's really cool but my wife was
raised a certain way
and my wife is raised how
america would be used marijuana yeah my
wife was one of those people me too so
was i if you go to that area if you see
when i travel i go to different areas
and i talk to different people
i don't
want my marijuana use in front of people
like
except for on this show no no
this is this is what we do in the church
but i'm not i don't have a t-shirt with
bob marley out of the pile
right you're following me i don't have
none of that gear just because i stay
away from that stuff good that's lame
anyway like all that stuff i stay away
from this is i'm a kid right since i'm a
kid i would put them on it was lame when
we were kids there was one shirt that i
got a couple years ago from a wheat
store in hollywood
that would that was one of the best
t-shirts i ever got sometimes people
give you a t-shirt you wash them two
times you gotta give them to the
goodwill
sometimes people give you
something yeah two [ __ ] times you
gotta give it to good ones
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know happy
and cheesy t-shirts he's right yeah
sometimes it just gets just full of
money on your shirts and sometimes
people give you a t-shirt that you look
at and go
but after you wash it a few times and
where are you like oh this this t-shirt
got some [ __ ] life to this
[ __ ] look at this baby it just
so happened it was a pot plant it was a
yellow shirt with like a sort of a pop
play but i had camouflage shorts in
those days so it was a nice little mix
well you were like
just to keep your [ __ ] color coordinated
and i'll never forget one day i got a
job on uh my name is real oh i get the
from my first episode and i look i go
let me put on my camouflage shorts and i
put the camouflage shorts on i put this
t-shirt on without even [ __ ] thinking
without even thinking i put this t-shirt
and i walk on the scene like you know uh
get comfortable they're gonna go eat in
about a half hour you're invited to go
eat lunch and then we'll after that
we'll get you makeup and [ __ ]
at that [ __ ] lunch i forgot that i
had this weed t-shirt oh my god
that's not gonna do well i had no
everybody kept coming up to me going man
we love you and i'm like what the [ __ ]
do they love i don't even know who the
[ __ ] i am yeah i said my lines yet
nobody [ __ ] knows me
these [ __ ] this t-shirt was driving
people crazy it was that cool of his
shirt you know what i did with it i
donated it did you that was nice once i
had the baby i'm like i'm too old to
wear a shirt with [ __ ] did i like do
like an auction for something or just
got rid of no i go to goodwill i go
right over here on van nuys probably
could have made a lot of money i bring
the bags now
kid you can give the money the chair
it's crazy i have these posters no
longer this yard
when the longest shot first came out
they gave me these little small posters
and they kept me on the poster
and it was a great little poster and
they gave me a bunch of them i don't
know what happened to them and when i
moved i found them
and i said you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do a raffle for charity
give it to the people listen to the
church autograph it for them
and someday they could do something with
them
and one day i'm sitting there like oh
let me go on [ __ ] ebay
and see if they even got this poster on
here but you put their ass they got it
for like [ __ ] ten dollars i'm like
this [ __ ] ain't worth dick if you signed
it and then you did it then
these idiots in england are selling
bottled air bottled clean air to people
in china
for like a hundred dollars a bottle
it was the stupidest what do you do with
it how do you i don't know i don't know
if you open in your i i couldn't even
look at the video i think it was on like
the news off the let me look it up
it's like a hundred bucks
did you eat a star celia no did you take
a bite of the stuff no you gotta take a
little bite of them
away they'll believe you though i think
you're from the fbi
i'll smoke the vape but no way that'll
do me in and then i won't be able to
talk anymore and i'll do the vape i got
i got kids
they'll see the computer and they'll
there's a bomb yeah
that's it
it's a [ __ ] british guy 27 year old
selling it for 115 a bottle
the company is called a
e t h a e r
you shouldn't [ __ ] help him lean
maybe buy yourself a bottle i did do a
bong hit of that that's pretty amazing i
tried to tell you whatever it's not even
the reed it's the [ __ ] bong that bong
is called the mule
the mule does not [ __ ] around see people
show up with big bongs
and they think that that's wait why
what's special about it that look that
kicks like a [ __ ] meal the training
on that bomb
this bong is the real is the last listen
i've had every size bung there is
and
the big ones sometimes they're hard to
[ __ ] hold and suck at the same time
and really get your balance so many
jokes but i'm gonna
this thing right here this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] here has uh what's the
black guy kat williams this [ __ ]
[ __ ] right here this [ __ ] right here
this is the bong of death
so you smoked all through college
where'd you go to college i went to
college at ithaca college look at you
and [ __ ] yeah that's it and you know
there's some good weed up there so i
smoked a lot of pot then and i smoked i
smoked a ton after college for that
matter put myself through grad school
smoke pot the whole way became a
counselor that's a mental health
counselor and it's at a school counselor
for that matter and uh
and then we moved up to ithaca to my my
now ex-husband and i moved up to ithaca
to start a family and he had a job up
there at a theater i started working
with at-risk kids
and so that i could get pregnant i was
like i'm not i'm done i'm not going to
smoke pot anymore and uh and so i didn't
i got pregnant with my first daughter
and then after i had her i had
[ __ ] terrible
uh postpartum depression i don't know if
terry went through that but it was
horrible i mean i could not get out of
bed i cried it it's like they put me on
a bunch of pharmaceuticals i was on um
prozac for a while and that helped
definitely helped like i could at least
stop crying and like didn't
you know feel like i didn't
love my kid which i i felt like nothing
for my my child and that sucked and i
didn't want to hurt her or anything but
i definitely thought about hurting
myself because i just so i felt so
guilty that i didn't feel anything for
her and then they started prescribing me
like oh god you know xanax and valium
and uh sleeping pills and stuff like
that because like i just changed after i
i had her i was really even when i
wasn't crying anymore i was just like
super anxious and i didn't and i got
lots of like rage and stuff it was
[ __ ] up
and then i kind of got it under control
i wasn't smoking pot then either how
long was this like well i had like the
sobbing parts where i was just like
could not get out of bed and like didn't
feel anything for her that probably went
on for almost a month
and then uh
the anxiety like never went away and
they just kept trying to give me other
meds and that sucked and then i got
pregnant again i went through a couple
years of trying to get pregnant and
taking infertility drugs which you know
if you ever want to see somebody go
completely [ __ ] crazy give them
infertility drugs
because like
holy crap i had a friend that used to
sell her eggs for cocaine
she used to sell her eggs that's not
funny this [ __ ] she was pretty
she was about 20 22 and 23. oh my god
she moved on here she was confused and
[ __ ]
who was buying her eggs knowing that
that's actually she went to some clinic
she stayed clean
and then they would give her the big
paycheck and she was a waitress at the
laugh factory
but she was selling that's a
[ __ ] process to go through you know
they had to come get a dog i bet like
the family had to come here and get him
and take her away
dude that's no joke and she was yelling
abe lincoln
holy [ __ ] how many eggs can you sell i
don't know she was there but you make
them you know she was don't she was an
egg making machine but you got to take
drugs to get them yes they were giving
her the drugs and she was snorting blow
and she i don't think that's allowed dog
it doesn't really matter it's like
it's like what i'm telling you about my
wife like my wife is straight she's
raised straight so my wife was raised
to believe a certain thing about
marijuana
and for years she was at the comedy
store she was exposed to it she just
never liked it
and then her and i started dating and
she realized that i was i would go
downstairs and smoke and
you know when you first start dating
people you accept things
you accept things because you're you're
hoping you'll get rid of those things
with her she was drinking and i was
smoking and i was doing a lot of other
things
but she didn't know those things then
she caught on after a while
but that's not here or there what
the point i'm getting to is
after about a year and a half one day i
came upstairs and she goes why do you
need to smoke
you know and i explained to her that i
had been smoking since i was a kid wait
why do you to help your like anxiety
help you focus or make you creative or
listen i think everyone has their own
please explain something let me be
honest it makes you feel good all these
emotions
didn't become public for about 15 years
ago before then there was no anxiety
there was no [ __ ] there was we just
didn't talk there was no insomnia yeah
nobody talked about that [ __ ] you just
felt [ __ ] up when i was a kid yeah you
were just an [ __ ] when i was a kid i
felt [ __ ] up me too and whenever i
smoked pot
it made me feel balanced whenever i
drank alcohol it was this yearning
feeling like that would give me anxiety
like i wanted to do but i couldn't like
i was getting held back when you do
cocaine that's a certain
horrible thing never done cocaine you
know any of those drugs but when i
smoked reefer i was home
yeah and it took terry
me to say terry can you sit down for a
second oh number one i'm never gonna
quit smoking but
i'm never gonna question what about if
you go home and meet my parents i don't
really give a frenchman's [ __ ]
i'll take a walk around the corner i go
for some people it's a cocktail for some
people it's playing tennis
for some people
for me
it's
there's nothing like going for a walk
with
a walkman or an ipad on or whatever the
[ __ ] they call an ipod
and having music on and smoking a joint
walking a mile and clearing your head
yeah
and if you have a problem that's your
solution you'll get it by the end of
that walk marijuana will help you attain
that that's how i always
felt about it
i i feel similarly and i gave it up
because i like i said i was raised like
terry my parents were
you know not into it at all and my uh
and my stepdad he came into our lives
when i was uh 14 and he like i said you
know he was pretty pretty famous
musician
and my mom made him give up all all weed
booze everything drugs like nothing he
couldn't do anything but that meant that
when i was going out and smoking pot if
i came home and he was there
i could get [ __ ] busted like fast and
there was one time that i came in and i
reeked of it i knew it and she knew it
and my mom was like not having it and i
you know she said like i know you were
at sam fine's house and you know you got
high and i was like what no i'm not high
i'm not high i don't smoke and she was
like harvey come here come here and
smell smell her and look at her and tell
me if she's high my stepdad who looks
like jerry garcia if you don't know who
he is google him his name's harvey
brooks looks like jerry garcia gets in
my face and just like stares at me and
i'm thinking [ __ ] i'm so [ __ ] busted
and he just like
nods looks at my mom and he's like nope
she's good she's totally not high and
she was like
oh
okay i'm sorry and walks out he just
looks at me he goes
i want a quarter pounder with cheese
i want fries
i want a milkshake tomorrow on the top
of the stairs in the basement
you don't tell your [ __ ] mother and i
was like
done
like he had me so busted and she
wouldn't let him eat [ __ ] like that so
like i went out and got him everything
like left it like an offering at the top
of his steps because i was like don't
tell on me and i lied i mean i got
caught with i got caught with weed in my
bag and my mom found it and like took it
out and i came in and it was like
sitting on the counter so i walked by
and i like did the double tick when i
was like oh [ __ ] like
yeah jewish moms don't [ __ ] around i was
i wasn't even high and my mom did this
to me when she just came up to me
are you high messed up on my and i
wasn't high but
she would look for the eye that's why i
never did it i
i smoked i made a nose for it my mom's
always like i think i was like 16 17
maybe that was the first time yeah geez
that was late my mom died when i was 15
and a half and
i hid it from her you didn't and i knew
she got high yeah why'd you hide it from
her you knew she got high and she knew
i got high but she didn't
because one time she got in a bind for
weeds she has one of my friends
okay but maybe she was baiting him or
something because he goes you know your
mama and an off-color asked me if i get
a weed
and i brushed it off like i didn't know
what he was talking about
yeah i mean no i hit it from you well
see so here's the thing this and this is
why i've been trying to you know change
this conversation and and i think it's
so interesting that like you'd say to
your wife that you know
like you don't give a [ __ ] if her
parents know that you smoked but you
told me that you don't want your your
daughter to ever know that you smoke no
not right now well not right now i get
it she's not the next couple years i
don't want her that my almost
six-year-old today asked me as i walked
out the door mom what's weed
and i said that's just another thing
they call cannabis and she was like oh
okay no there's gonna be questions yeah
no it's gonna be quiet will you ever
smoke it in front of her i'm not sure
not right now i'll dodge
i'll dodge the questions i'll explain to
her as much as i can wait but what
happens if you just normalize it like so
my kids are i mean given it's this has
like been a thing like for the past year
they've sort of caught on i i i hit it
and i as i was gonna say about the
postpartum stuff you know i uh i got
when i finally did have my other kid my
second kid and after i had her like i
was not right still but i wasn't like a
sobbing mess but i was like you know i'm
not i still don't really feel right but
i had like you know bad anxiety and i
was talking to uh my friend tom grubbs
who who actually you know um is a
partner at this farm in uh in forest
grove oregon uh moto perpetual pharma
and he was like you're not right like
you've known me since high school so
he's like you don't act like something's
off and i told him like i haven't been
right since i had my kid and he was like
you know
do you still smoke pot i was like what
no i'm a mom i don't smoke that anymore
like i got really judgy and pissy with
him and he was like okay and they said
you know i really kind of think that
like might level you out like exactly
what you were just saying and he's like
you should try that i really think that
might work for you
and i thought about it and i thought
about it and i was like you know i
always really loved smoking pot and it's
exactly what you said like that i just
felt okay leveled out something about
that drug right does it
makes me feel like i'm home right right
listen i could sit here and sit and give
me a blow smoke up your ass and tell you
no it's a year i'm gonna quit smoking
dogs yeah no i'm never quitting that
about it i thought about it because i'm
not getting as high i don't get the
results i want to
as when we first started i wanted to i
want to [ __ ] drool
i have such a system
what about dabs have you tried that no
that's too strong i can't have a torch
in my house you don't have to have a
blowtorch you can use it like the the
hot nail no no in place
have you done that
have i done dabs and you haven't we've
done them in here oh it's just too much
work for what i wanted uh but you've
seen the hot nail that you plug in right
yeah that's like a totally different
thing no no no no i don't want none of
that stuff in the house i really like
those i like my little pipes how i like
to fly i have a dab
i have my little pipe i have a [ __ ]
stick to clean it out with those kebabs
i like a bun i steal from my wife you go
out in the backyard i got a secret
compartment i go out in the backyard
i zip it up and i put it back in the
sinking compartment and nobody knows
[ __ ] nothing okay so i have a cabinet
that all my weeds in you can see it and
like any you know bong or my bowl
whatever my kids know where it is i have
it locked and i have the key but they
know where it is and like they'll come
in and i'll have it i'll have it open
and my older one will be like smells
like marijuana in here why were you in
the cabinet but i'll vape in front of
them my my older one and when i'm being
uh i mean because obviously tom was
right and you know the weed worked and
and so i've been using it ever since for
postpartum depression and for anxiety
i'm a better parent my daughter my older
daughter will go into my bag and find
this and and give it to me like when
it's in its case and hand it to me and
be like mom do you do you think maybe
you know you want to smoke some pot
because you seem like you're having a
really hard time and she's not wrong
and you know what when we were growing
up like kids made and you know earlier
than that kids made their parents drinks
and stuff you know like all the sally
draper mad men type of thing which by
the way you know my daughter knows how
to make a couple drinks also but
don't i just don't we take the taboo off
so that they're not brainwashed like we
were brainwashed like terry was
brainwashed like i was brainwashed you
know and thinking that like this is the
gateway drug so if my kids just grow up
a round pot they don't ever feel like
they have to hide it from me they'll ask
me about it they know it's something
that actually helps me and that makes me
feel better and then in the i'm a better
parent to them because i'm all leveled
out and you know if one of them's like
making an annoying noise sitting next to
me for 10 minutes i don't want to kill
her because you know that's annoying i
can sit through you know a [ __ ]
barbie movie if i'm high like and i
don't mean get so high i can't parent
but
to just not feel
you know kids are annoying you've got
one there's a lot of considerations here
there's a lot of considerations number
one
what if you went to a movie and
something bad would have happened i
won't get high though i wouldn't get
high and you were high but i wouldn't be
and nothing happened when you got in the
car nothing happened i don't draw i
don't drive with my whatever you got in
the uber or whatever
what i'm saying is that if you're gonna
feel bad that you were high there's so
many aspects but you don't you can smoke
pot and not be high is my point no
everybody's different everybody has a
different situation remember when i sent
my daughter down and i have to talk with
her it's not just going to be about
marijuana right
it's going to be no no no no you don't
have no [ __ ] idea but you got to talk
about all drugs sure no there's not all
drugs
i got to talk to how i put a machine
into somebody's head and kidnapped him
and did four years in prison so my
situation that's so bad so you
understand my situation a little bit
more different than yours right i'm sure
when she goes to her grammar school
in this area they're going to have a dad
program
and someday she's going to come home and
go daddy what do you know
and i got to talk to him bob and weave a
little bit i can't drop it out of her
when she's [ __ ] sick this story goes
from a to b to c to your grandmother
dying
but you know what okay but listen to
this because my my older daughter uh
when last year uh they had to do the
dare poster because that's still like a
[ __ ] thing right they do dare poster
and when like her and her friends are
designing the dare poster and putting
all the drugs on one of her friends was
like oh we got to put the you know the
pot leaf on and my daughter was like no
we don't that's really not a drug that
should be in this like at all that helps
people and and my sister is fighting
cancer and she's you know been using
cannabis for that and my daughter knows
it and she was like my aunt she has
cancer and that's helping her
and her friend sophie uh ryan has been
fighting cancer same thing using pop for
that and uh who's like you know what i
think four sophie's four and um
and so uh and her teacher agreed they
took it off so that dare poster had uh
the other drugs but not pot so all i'm
saying is like if we could take pot away
out of that
and like put that someplace else you
know it's safer than alcohol and i don't
get i really don't get hot
with my kids listen listen listen you're
going in the wrong direction no no
you're
i'm old school i have old school values
and i grew up and seen it plus i sold it
to other families right i sorted it to
other families
you mean all drugs no no no no i'm
talking about even the simple cocktails
in front of your kids and telling your
kids you're hammered from the night
before
i grew up in those families so i saw
from a different perspective i have an
old-school way of belief
i have an old school belief and that and
a child and a parent's relationship
i really [ __ ] do
because once you let one thing slip you
gotta let everything slip so with me
parenting is in courses
i have i had a mom
who got high and stuff that i
appreciated not really i looked at the
other aspects of her life and she was
really solid
and she turned me into my wife
i saw a woman that got up at eight and
went into the city and went to hell's
kitchen and got meat when there was
still the meat in packing district and
then we'd go buy some music then we'd
bring it back to union city and take a
[ __ ] cab to the to yankee stadium uh
chased him to watch the match then come
home she'd cook for me so i came from a
different lifestyle yes i've seen a
different type of woman and what the
[ __ ] they're doing i went to the bar at
night
i saw what they were doing and i turned
the cheek
do you know what i'm saying yeah i
didn't want that
i sit here and i cringe
i cringe once a week at night
of the thought of if my mom
wouldn't have died
because
my mom died a month before the
marielle harbor got opened
that was in 1980 when they let out 200
000 savage cubans out of all the jails
fidel got rid of him
and they infused miami and northern new
jersey and their whole mission was to
spread folk [ __ ] cocaine that was
their whole mission
and how old were you when all this went
down i was 16 february that year when
marielle and all that [ __ ] but
there's times i think
my situation would have got infused with
cocaine
and where would that have left my mom
and my's relationship would i had done
coke if she would have lived
i did coke a month before she died
like i held out as much as i [ __ ]
could
and to this day i feel terrible about it
you know that i even did that type of
stuff like but you have to live your
everybody has their own sorrows and
their own pains
so
i i dig this [ __ ] you do i you know i
didn't go i forgot the name of the
website
but the whole purpose of this was that
you
wrote this blog
you write this blog and it's
pretty much about mommies and shoes and
raising your kids and [ __ ] like this and
i did write one about you know my
daughter finding my sex toys too right
and after three [ __ ] years and it's
interesting right you get a lot of
people who read it especially a lot of
moms and after
three years you dropped this [ __ ]
story on them that
you
believe that marijuana
not only helps but cuba's postpartum
depression you know what man i don't
even have postpartum depression i've
read about it and i know you're correct
i know that if they took nine women 10
women that have postpartum depression i
know for a fact that six of them would
go you know what
i feel a lot better now let's get a
milkshake yup you know what i'm saying
like i know this in my heart
but it's very tough
to sell
terry clark this oh i know i know
so yes it's taking place
it's taken me 17 years
and i never imposed marijuana and my
wife never
never said to her you should get i
never never no no no she won't she'll
get pissed off
she she didn't want you know she just
and i respected it and that was it and
then at the wedding
i was smoking hash and she goes is that
hashtag oh yeah she goes can i take a
hit she took one hit and that was it
and never again she goes this [ __ ] made
me feel [ __ ] terrible as it did when
i was in college [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and that was it
and then she hurt her back
and i couldn't take it no more you have
no [ __ ] idea at night with the ice
packs and the rubbing my back
and i got to the [ __ ] besides
i got a [ __ ] massage package
and she's yeah then she still came home
with the rub my back [ __ ] and i take
it to the chinese guy for 20 hour happy
hour when they rub your feet they pull
your neck
yeah no i don't know i'm listening i'm
no [ __ ] joey masseuse you got me for
about three minutes and [ __ ]
i do i give two types of massage to your
neck for three minutes and the sensual
ones that's about two and a half till
the panties come off then the massage is
over you understand me there's no more
[ __ ] massage you need to you need to
get her the the weed uh
spray to put down there
yes you do you do that is how you get
her hooked in you need the empower
foreplay that's what you need [ __ ]
around with the [ __ ] ice packs
and i'm gonna go get a needle and i
finally sat it down and i go here's the
deal you know i love you and my wife but
the shit's got a [ __ ] end first off
my ears are bleeding you're making the
insides of my [ __ ] ears bleed with
the [ __ ] back stuff okay
okay you got to knock it off you're not
getting another one of those shots you
can't get one oh the cortisone shots the
problem is you got the [ __ ] shot and
instead of stretching in the backyard
and [ __ ] around you sit on your ass
with a [ __ ] ice pack you believe
everything the [ __ ] doctor tells you
i'm telling you you got to get blood to
that area you got to give that area of
blood i'm the one that made us start
walking around the [ __ ] park oh good
i go you got to go walk around the park
those quarters well i gotta go do this
no you know no you got nothing to do you
got nothing to [ __ ] do go get the
[ __ ] out of here and she walks around
the park now she's like i like what
doing i do three loops now yeah you do
three loops [ __ ] beautiful that's why
we live here so you go to the [ __ ]
park but she won't try cannabis for the
pain of the background hold on slow the
[ __ ] down
so i start taking hypnotherapy
and the chicks telling me how she's a
yoga teacher i said let me tell you
something get my wife out of the house
and the youngest listen to the show and
the hypnotherapist like what are you
talking about
what days you teach yoga what type of
yogi teacher is this soft yoga salt
i go where's the classroom what time she
gave me everything
uh honey you're gonna go to yoga she
goes i can't my back listen
you're gonna keep not chanting until how
[ __ ] long how long are we gonna hear
i [ __ ] i can't
because then you're never going to do it
you're 46 it's only going to get worse
i go go down there whatever you can't do
you bow out and whatever you can do you
buy in right that's it this is an easy
magoo but at least you try to get some
blood to that area you got to give these
areas blood
guess what she went
she went again
she went again she went for a walk
she went again she went an extra day she
went to basic yoga 101. nice so i go so
the pain is going away
so we had a conversation about xanax
and she's like it's starting to bother
me
i go listen i love it on the road
but when i'm home i got these stars of
debt
i mix it up
i got chocolate bars
i got wacky taffy you know what i'm
saying like i got mixed up
candy store i go terry i got some cbd oh
it's one to one
do me a favor
what time you want to be in bed she goes
i'm gonna be in bed about 10 and 15. go
listen
at about nine o'clock
do two sprays under your tongue and she
looked at me at first
it was just the cb it had any it had thc
in it [ __ ] yeah 100
so somebody like her will feel it she'll
sleep like a [ __ ] baby listen she
[ __ ] around with that gobagoba
melatonin and all that [ __ ] works three
nights and then your resistance goes up
and you're [ __ ] right you actually
depend on them like i'm gonna take three
of these not nothing's gonna happen
they're done
she drinks the kanakana tea
the woo-woo tea everything puts you to
sleep for a night and then you know
there's no more sleeping and i could
hear her teeth grinding
at night i could hear her teeth grinding
so i told us it wasn't anything they're
gonna object but just listen to me hear
me out just hear me out
i got a call from a friend of mine
he called me
he told me he needed cbd or he wanted to
try it i brought him a [ __ ] the best
cbd or one to one
like i gave him the cbdo he's my brother
i grew up with him i don't give a [ __ ]
take it
he calls me back two months later and
then we're talking he goes listen i want
to thank you for the cb deal i go why
he goes well he goes i got a dog who's
got cancer
and he goes his numbers were going down
his kidneys
i don't know you know i'm not a doctor
ladies and gentlemen i don't know the
thing my friend is from jersey also he's
crazy like me
and i can hear his he goes i've had this
dog for 13 years also when he gets
cancer
he goes i don't know what to do but his
numbers were going up he goes so i
started giving him two sprays every
night he goes what i got to lose he goes
guess what his numbers are going down
because he's still gonna die but he's
doing a lot [ __ ] better than what he
was doing so i go honey if it saved the
dog
give it a shot
and my wife's like what are you talking
about i'm like just give one shot an
hour and a half before you want to go to
bed
and she gave it a shot
and the next day i said what do you
think
and she goes i don't think it was enough
oh that's awesome sorry go do two
she did two and now she does three at
night dog
come on she went was she don't think she
would eat an edible no really even one
that just said like one milligram listen
to me oh i tell these people on the
[ __ ] time
i tell these people on the air and i try
to tell him
listen when you guys see me and lee and
chocolates
and all this [ __ ] it's cute
it's really cute people but let me tell
you something
the best edibles you'll ever make are
the ones you make in your own living
room in your own kitchen
how do i know
i'm gonna tell you guys a little story
i meet terry in 2000
we moved in together maybe nine months
later
you know i'm busy as [ __ ] on the road as
a feature act i'm hoping for joe rogan
i'm starting to do movies little by
little
you know she knows of my drug use she
kind of yeah
you know i would meet her at the store
and have a few drinks
and uh
what the [ __ ] was i gonna tell you
edibles making your own edibles and one
day i hear about this edible [ __ ] i go
to houston texas and my buddies in
houston turned me on to brownies and i
ate one one night and on stage i saw
purple spots and [ __ ] yeah
and i pulled them out what the [ __ ] do
you put in these
and he told me and all right i'm gonna
go home and do the same thing you do
and it was me my wife and his girl
andrea
all right so it was a sunday night we
went down there and i hosted
and andrea and my wife came later on and
they worked that's when they were
waitresses at the comedy store and when
i took off about 12 30 those girls came
home it was like a memorial day weekend
like a labor day weekend mm-hmm
so we went back to my house and andrea
and my wife ate
while i was gonna make brownies at one
in the morning okay so
i [ __ ] whip up the box of chocolate
fudge whatever the [ __ ] they send you i
put the [ __ ] almonds in there you
know whatever the [ __ ] they send you the
chocolate almond butter crocker
and i take uh butter i throw in the fine
print and the lowest level that i could
throw it
i take this weed i dry it really good it
was from uh
a friend of mine and i took an eighth of
it i grinded it down i took all the
stems out i cleaned it
and i let this butter and just simmer
and i would throw the weed in there
i would throw little bits of weed until
it was fine and then i would just
squeeze the weed until the butter turned
green
and i would dip it on the brownie then i
would do the same pot and i would mix
this into a [ __ ] brownie and you know
i would lick the spoon a little bit and
i would come back and do this and this
went on for 20 30 35 minutes until i
cooked all the [ __ ] weed
and even then i took the weed and put it
back and did another batch of butter
with it and took it all the way [ __ ]
down and drained another [ __ ] three
ounces of [ __ ] thc juice into this
chocolate brownie mix and i whip this
[ __ ] up and there's a law and order
maritime going on so i'm on fire
i already licked the spoon three times
i went downstairs and smoked a joint i
probably got a xanax in me something i
got something in me
i put the [ __ ] brownies in the thing
i think i'm out
and
it's about two in the morning and we're
all sitting there the next thing you
know
the girls go in the kitchen they're like
man that smells good andrea was
straighter than my wife oh my god
she was from the south also
they didn't like that [ __ ] they would
have a few drinks and listen to kid rock
but everything else isn't gonna [ __ ]
work out for you
they come back and they look me straight
in the facely
and we do that question was
if you know your uncle joey
what do you think they asked me and what
do you think i told them
i feel like i could answer this so you
better be able to i have no idea i'm hot
as [ __ ] right now i'm sorry the girls
came out and said is that whole thing
thc and you said no oh no half of it is
thc
and the half of it is straight up i
totally would have gotten that they
looked at me
i was high from the three spoons
but when i went in there and cut a piece
of brownie a little one and i gave them
each a little piece and then i ate
another piece we went out there and
started watching law and order
and those girls with me started getting
high higher
higher higher by 8 in the morning we
couldn't even go to bed we were [ __ ]
up those girls were [ __ ] up
and they were loving it like my wife's
eyes were beat red andrea's eyes were
beat red
i [ __ ] fell asleep in the bed my wife
fell asleep on the couch and dre fell
asleep on the floor oh my god i thought
you're going to be nice to your wife
that was nice we woke up like at four in
the afternoon
hungry as [ __ ] giggling so why wouldn't
you do it again this sounds like a
lovely listen to my wife got so [ __ ]
high
she couldn't go to work and the whole
thing
so that was the end of that you know i'm
like
i'm going to give you my advice
don't even ask her
don't even ask her you don't want to
know let me give some shout outs here
real quick
all right j
mc fanatic
salad bowl grinder jfag six
angel rodriguez per zangerberg
for
persengerberg i like that name and [ __ ]
floyd 79
justin wood
jimmy nunya
and d in colorado i love you
[ __ ] don't forget thursday
night flappers and then next thursday
the weekend at the brand [ __ ]
improv [ __ ]
so let me answer this yeah so now you do
this blog for the [ __ ] three years
and you put a blog in there about reefer
solving all this and who gets mad at you
oh my god
everyone got mad at me
people unsubscribe and stuff like that
well advertisers pulled out no okay so
this
this magazine is based out of where your
blog is basically well yeah we're like a
mom website and it's based out of la and
we have you know we sell advertising
space and and uh one company that will
remain nameless was actually uh wanted
my older daughter to do like um
influencing you know online for their
brand and i would have had her instagram
account like i had control over it and
once i came out about supporting
cannabis they they pulled out and said
nope never mind we don't want to touch
that
so i mean it was you know brands big
pharma that was you know one of them it
was yeah they had no interest in i could
tell you way
ahead of time that
i think people are still very confused
yeah mentality no no the mentality is
still there
there's still that old american
mentality
that marijuana and there's nothing you
could [ __ ] do i don't know you know
what though your
your buddy joe rogan said it really
really well like pretty recently and he
said you know we we take all these
pharmaceuticals we don't know what's in
them we just believe what the government
tells us that's safe that's safe that's
safe we take it you know what i believe
i believe that the farm that uh is
helping my sister and has helped me
where i can go and walk around that
greenhouse and i know the people that
are you know raising that crop do an
amazing job and it's organic and i see
where it comes from and people really
give a [ __ ] and that this is a natural
thing and i am worried about big pharma
being involved and they're going to be
involved plus like there's you know sort
of corporate cannabis stuff now i like a
small farm that's doing good i'm into
that as a mom and that's hard to argue
with that let's go to the store in the
corner and get weed
i don't want to go to the farm this guy
i want to get a [ __ ] farm yeah but
you're not a mom what would terry do
terry goes to whole foods right listen
doesn't she doesn't know terry don't
give a [ __ ] about this oh come on yeah
she's like all yogi and blah blah terry
doesn't know anything about this weeds
no not weed regular stuff that she that
she goes to a bunch of different places
that's what i'm saying but she wants to
try like all the herbs right three or
four different soups right so why can't
we all the things you she was taking
before you know go to bed like to me
you know she got that whole food you
don't know where it came from or what
the government put in that but i do know
what you know what's in cannabis what's
in wheat i like to call cannabis because
it sounds no no
i agree with you on all these facts
right the only thing i'm trying to
explain to you is this is all great [ __ ]
i know people aren't ready
yeah no go on my yahoo article and read
some of the comments people said oh no
the people the people that
listen man this is old america
and and
and
there was supposed to be a war in drugs
that was never [ __ ] won it was just
exposed and there was a war that was
that that that [ __ ] failed miserably
and you know every generation has a
different drug feliz that generation it
was to do ecstasy and jump up and down
when the jewish kids came i did a fair
amount of exercise whatever we all have
something different
and to some people marijuana is included
in that circle
and there's nothing you could do but
isn't there for the next generation by
doing what i'm doing if i start this
conversation now and my kids grow up
thinking it's no big deal your kids grow
up thinking it's no big deal and it
falls more into
well that's kind of like tylenol or you
know and and and a kind of you know
alcohol that we don't touch but we sort
of can use recreationally and to make us
feel better don't we change their view
if we do this now
do what like if i if my kids growing up
now this change it so it's not like
hush-hush hiding it trying to blush in
my kids if you get in your [ __ ] car
today and you go to [ __ ] sunset
boulevard and make a right they're gonna
see all this [ __ ] no but they're gonna
see all these [ __ ] billboards and
eventually one day they're going to come
and ask you no mine already asked right
i understand that
and i'm [ __ ] happy for you but one
day they're going to come and ask you
and you have to talk to them and explain
to them and that all takes time right
but
but if you just sort of integrate it
quite like into it like it's not just i
don't need to integrate it that's the
problem i don't really want to integrate
it every you know there's a family
there's got to be a [ __ ] family moral
somewhere and there's kind there has to
be somewhere why is that that's tomorrow
and there's an age and at some ages
there's some [ __ ] that they should not
be exposed to
think about that can you drink a beer or
anything in front of your no you won't
drink no no
no
no
then when you're 16 you're at the club
with your [ __ ] stupid girlfriends
drinking wine talking about how your 16
year old [ __ ] [ __ ] and with drinking
yeah that's how it starts
with the stupidity that's how it starts
with the stupidity
with no his dad did my dad his dad did
but his mom is by the book yeah my mom
is
i've seen him listen i love i love what
you're talking about here in star celia
but no i like i like you i know and i
saw i i listened i saw families
that were catholic as [ __ ]
that i used to go to a house and eat
italian food
and nobody would curse and then drugs
started coming on the scene and two of
the kids died
this isn't my point i also saw people
that
grew up with kids that didn't do drugs
but the parents played cards
and on the weekends they play cards and
drink
and we would go to the houses and
because the parents went on drink he
would have parties at his house
today that kid's a [ __ ] boozer yeah
is it because
so for me what was the cause of that
booze that his parents weren't home they
weren't [ __ ] around
[ __ ] around yes marching [ __ ]
around but that's [ __ ] around
absolutely and then you get mad what is
my daughter what did my son doing so in
my world i saw it from a lot of
different perspective i'm 54.
i don't even like to talk about what i'm
going to teach because
i'm alive today and i get to spend time
with her and sit with her
listen man i was exposed to things at
young ages i never should have been
exposed
i never should have been exposed as
simple as that that sounds like it never
should have been exposed i still love
that i shot a gun
you know
in those days it was in those days there
was a thing called the pal
the police athletic league yeah and
after school if your parents didn't have
enough money you signed up and you went
to the police athletic league they took
everybody because they had a pool table
they [ __ ] sharpened guns they taught
you how to clean
gun you know they told you that you
served lunches to homeless people
it was a [ __ ] adventure then this was
before
this
way of you know
i mean we're all looking for a better
[ __ ] america every you know if you
take your child to these schools
in malibu and whatever i mean before i
even had a child i would go to barbecues
at my friend's house and they would talk
about how they had to pull their kids
out of malibu high
because of the amount of drugs drugs
yeah you know they tried to put them in
a private school they had more drugs
yeah the more money the more drugs the
more money the more totally you know so
i'm sitting here going like
right now i'm sitting here going where
do i move this child
but on the other hand i want you to know
something uh celia what's up brother but
i like i grew up in one of the nicest
i mean towns in
in the state where i grew up but even
where i grew up it used to be called
drinking drugs berry that my high school
there's been drugs in high school yeah
forever
not until i was like 16 or 17 now and i
barely just smoked weed and took i took
my first edible
uh one of those five minutes ago
homemade brownies
so
this is my point it's everywhere joey
like it's everything you can't get away
with
so that so that's where i get to like
why how if we're sheltering them like
you're gonna see it on tv and now they
have screens and they're all you there's
youtube like you they're gonna get into
it so isn't it better now if we
introduce it to them as kids i think
like my question is because i i've seen
cnn's on some pretty interesting shows
really interesting on this subject and i
think one of the parents had a uh
dispensary near or in their house or
something to that effect and they got
their kids taken away from them if i'm
not mistaken probably well i don't know
no no unless the kid got into it that
they shouldn't have gotten them taken
away for that or or unless it was
illegal was it an illegal operation i
haven't done the research but um i could
i'll look it up and see if i can find it
but my question is like do you worry now
that it's gone a little viral let any
say how open you are with it because
even though i'm losing my kids you mean
well do you even not for like not full
time but like
they could contest it or maybe your
ex-husband i'm not sure what like i
don't know no uh no because i my kids
aren't i mean
it's the same as having alcohol it's a
legal state and i have a card and it's
locked up uh from them they don't have
access to it um and so actually it's not
a child protective issue and so cps
wouldn't have a case unless i was
getting them high or i was getting so
stoned that i couldn't parent but that's
what i'm saying i'm not i don't do that
i micro dose to control anxiety i use it
like it's medication and i don't hide
that from my kids okay that makes sense
not that i never get high i certainly
will but my kids are not home when i do
that how's that and they don't know that
part
like i don't i don't say sometimes mommy
gets so high that she needs to go to bed
like i don't say that i uh
i really like what you're wrong about
the menopause piece
and i like that you're getting grief i i
turn you on to a different doctor to go
down there and
talk about this [ __ ] you know about the
the causes i mean
yeah it helps it helps menopause it
helps ppd it helps you know pms i uh
i don't know i i've been like i told you
see that i grew up in a drug environment
i know you're it's a different story i
uh no no no no i bought weed when i was
young i love wheat i'll sit here and
grasp you on the microphone
have a bible and i love marijuana and i
gotta look in the eye and tell you that
i don't know how i feel about legalized
marijuana until this day i don't know
how i feel i feel a lot better than i
did five years ago i know that
the cbd oil is helping me yes
i know that i had a [ __ ] up knee
and i bought some tremendous cbd spray
and i sprayed it on my [ __ ] knee and
my knee feels great i was waiting on the
[ __ ] epson thought you were going to
bring me i know until i forgot
you slipped up
i said i wanted to introduce it to the
[ __ ] world
you understand me that's going to be
that acupuncture that's that's that's
empower bodyguards
they're gonna get yourself
uh i wanna because i believe in a lot of
that yeah i still there's a lot of stuff
there's a lot of mysticism and [ __ ] that
i don't buy into still even though wait
what do you mean mysticism there's just
there's a level like a shaman with weeds
no no no no no i'm so sorry there's a
level of this whole movement
that i don't take oh yeah that people
think i dig and i really don't date
because i don't really give a [ __ ] which
which i don't really give a [ __ ] do you
understand me yeah you got the wrong guy
which part which brought the whole
jumping up and down
like i don't like weed festivals
i don't you know i think it's a
privilege yeah i think let's take it and
run with it shut up [ __ ] mouth
you know why be john gotti and rub it in
people's places shut the [ __ ] up and you
know what you know what ten years from
now
when there's a hundred people in the
hospital god forbid
god forbid god forgive me for saying
something like this but this is what's
gonna need to happen
this is what's gonna show
those people that we
are sitting here talking about that will
never flip
is for a picture of
people that have had cancer for six
eight months and and other people who
have beaten cancer
and said i sprayed this under my tongue
three times a day for six months and my
spots
you know went away or my uh boils went
down or whatever the terms is i'm sorry
yeah no like your tumors this is what's
gonna need to happen yeah on cnn
50 people saying i moved to colorado and
my son was getting epilepsy family and
he was jumping off windows and now look
at him he's doing ballet
he's skiing with one [ __ ] leg
that's what needs to happen well and
that but that is we need to see it there
but it is tell me your [ __ ] stories
we need to see right but that's
happening
i'm not saying to you you know i know i
don't
know
no no i'm just saying this i'm that that
part of the matter i agree you know but
there's always going to be
like it's not that i'm in a wheat store
11 years ago now at this point if you
came to me with the cbd [ __ ] i'd say
listen uh
my little cute jewish chick you're
licking nuts tonight and we your little
monkey and if we got nowhere i shook you
i don't have to listen to your cbd or
[ __ ] who's that trick [ __ ] her she
doesn't want to suck dick i'm gonna keep
her around trying to tell me cbd all
heals you this is when i was like stop
with the betsy ross flag
at this point i i don't want to hear
about your [ __ ] what do they call the
kush t-shirts what they call it oh yeah
yeah well i don't want to hear it i
didn't want to hear it and one day i go
to this weed store that's hidden
that's hidden this is where a couple
celebrities went
i didn't know about the business
celebrities i went there and bought
papers
and one of the guy goes you know we got
a weed stone here go no [ __ ]
and i went into the guy quit his job on
hollywood on us
and belly hills as a chef
and his brother opened up a weed store
and they got the fat guy
from the valley right around burbank
boulevard by whitsett there's a weed
there's a wait lee wake up i'm talking
about my mom
your [ __ ] [ __ ]
he needs your he
he invested and they opened up this
little weed store in the back but lisa
this guy was a baker
he understand me like a [ __ ]
beverly hills truffles that type of [ __ ]
his edibles were supreme you didn't even
you didn't even taste the mountain one
you would go joey you gotta give me that
one i don't give a [ __ ]
that's where they had to carry rodrigo
torres you ever hear the story we were
all in edibles and all of a sudden they
had to carry him to his car his legs are
dragging where'd he go we had to carry
him back to riverside no where did baker
go
did they [ __ ] closed it down they
didn't want to do it no more because
that's what i've been doing you know
what they were smoking too much yeah but
these guys i'm in there one day and they
had platinum they had this weak chick
they just did a profile on it on one of
these tv shows she was growing weed in
beverly hills and flying it and yanking
people
she they were getting her weed it was an
og this is 15 years ago nobody knew
about oh geez this chick was already
getting no g and sending it somewhere
else
and they were getting like one of the
only shipments from her in l.a was going
to that store and the rapper had that
show
lee
10 years ago 12 years ago a rapper had a
show on mtv where he would fix cars
exhibit
would go had exhibits
every day and buy an ounce of weed
something in my generation now that's
crazy like this is how this little weed
store you know who else wanted that
who's the chick that had the [ __ ] tv
show
on abc that talk [ __ ] and they canceled
it with three episodes left so she never
went indication
from the [ __ ] 90s uh
she was trying to make a comeback a few
years ago oh it wasn't she used to go in
there i used to see the craziest [ __ ]
celebrities in there
so one day i'm in there there's a dude
with a [ __ ] up haircut
like a marine haircut
i'm like this guy could be the narrow
and taxi drivers
he could just shoot everybody in here
and celia next thing you know
he bought like an hour to this you know
i was working this and
the guy started talking to him the big
fat guy pete and he goes well you live
around he goes now to be honest he had
to live here but
i had cancer and he goes it was the
weirdest thing oh yeah
i was a [ __ ] lieutenant colonel
rookie lake no damn it he's like i was
literally incredible
i was a lieutenant colonel in the
[ __ ] army for 20 years
for years i despised marijuana despised
it
and he goes i came back and i got cancer
and i lost 90 pounds and i was really
sick
and my son made me start smoking it
and i said no for weeks and one day i
took a chance and
it saved my life i started eating and
stuff and that's the first time i was
like
okay
all right my sister has stage four colon
cancer i get it now and that she's been
using rso which is you know rick simpson
oil and she was using suppositories so
you know she was getting her ass high
which was right on there and she would
never smoke pot i i smoked pot i always
tried to get my sister high and i wrote
a blog about this because it was like
i've you know i said i've been trying to
get her high since i was 14. i've
managed to do it twice and the first
time was when uh we were i was in like
right after college and i got her high
at my grandparents farm and we got like
the serious giggles and then the next
time was when she was diagnosed with
cancer and because she couldn't eat she
weighs 90 pounds and she was you know
she couldn't eat she was the chemo was
making her super nauseous and throwing
up and it had already metastasized by
the time they found it she's only 40
just turned 41 and she just had a baby
and so while she was pregnant this
cancer was growing her pregnancy
basically masked the fact that she had
colon cancer and um
she's you know
doctors won't say that this is what's
like done it but she's come so far i
cannot believe you're eating a whole one
of those uh she's come so far and that
if you're not a believer and you can't
believe after seeing somebody who has
cancer go through what you know they go
through and come back from it
just throwing stars at you why are they
wet do it why are they wet wait my
friend doesn't sweat
that makes them extra tasty no it don't
yeah
i love your blog i love what you do i
love that you have the balls
to write what you did because i love it
i like i can't really believe jesus
christ
in today's society so many women would
get mad but you have to expect it oh it
wasn't just women it was men too oh yeah
calling me a shitty parent telling me to
get my tubes tied
hope i don't have any more kids why do
you think it is not like you know what
moms can't have fun i think isn't that
[ __ ]
i think that's not fair i think that i
believe in mom's to [ __ ] see i was
raised by a single mom
so and she had a bar and she would dress
up and get dolled up i still remember
her going to the cheetah the cheetah was
the club before studio 54. you
understand me that's how deep my mom
watched
and i used to beg them take me to the
cheetah with you i had to be full i'd be
crying take me to the chain of four or
five like a little girl crying and she
got you [ __ ]
lee knock it off don't rebuke why not
stop with the puke
throw in your mouth and he's got stars
over there that we're playing look at
him he's tougher than that
pop the star eat the [ __ ] thing oh
yeah
this is constantly every day with this
guy
you know let me tell you something i
live
i have a 27 year old
oh i didn't know that no i don't talk to
nobody [ __ ] knows you know unless
somebody some people do
uh
and by the age of five i had made
mistakes around her
you know
she
was
a little from my cloth
one day she was watching tv in my living
room i would have her on
wednesdays from two to seven and she was
watching tv in my living room
and the chinese guy came with the
delivery and i bought us some food
and [ __ ] jesus christ
i couldn't get a highlight from one in
the afternoon now it's 6 30 i've
answered 80 questions
i've chased her and 22 bicycles you know
uh-huh like i'm a criminal and i'm
playing that for five [ __ ] hours
and i've been born there went out to the
porch
and i [ __ ] lit up a joint i had an
outdoor porch
and you know i went to blow the smoke
and she was walking up the stairs and
watching me
and my heart broke and i may believe
like it didn't happen
and
i don't know if she told the mother i
don't think she did she was like i said
she was a diaz at the time she was a
diaz
but that always i always thought about
that you know like i was like really
joey and what the [ __ ]
and then she saw me get into a fist
fight i didn't need a father to see that
that's when i was like that's it i gotta
stop this [ __ ]
because she's gonna grow up to be an
animal like me and i don't want to see
this [ __ ] and
i just uh
i don't know i have weird
like i said it's not weird it's it's
inevitable because
she's gonna come over there and ask
about
drinking or whatever the [ __ ] man i want
i'm gonna make a joke or whatever you
know i dread the questions
like they told her at school i was like
no they didn't tell her at school i was
a comedian they asked her if i was funny
and she said [ __ ] no
she doesn't say [ __ ] no she just goes no
he's not funny
so
you know she's like daddy why were they
asking me if you were funny i don't say
nothing about comedy
every once in a while nothing you do
here's funny what are you doing
yeah yeah yeah every once in a while i
slip and say show in front of her
and she looks at me like kind of weird
like she don't know i don't want to know
i'm a comedian to a certain age
i don't want her to go to your house
and be that [ __ ] kid
you following me don't tell me you don't
know what the [ __ ] i do
especially in this [ __ ] neighborhood
of course you go to parties here and
parents are going hold on one second and
they'll bang two spoons and all of a
sudden three little gay kids come out of
the living room dressed like each other
singing the [ __ ] beetles and you're
like where's my gun where's isis what
are you doing totally no
i am [ __ ] sorry celia i agree i am
sorry so i don't want to be in your
house one day with your nice jewish
[ __ ] family and the guitar player
jerry garcia and lee's there and a bunch
of other [ __ ] jews and all of a
sudden my kid breaks up
is this my car is this my god and you're
like what the [ __ ] awesome he starts
going listen i was doing lesbian tricks
in the first grade and you people like
no oh my god you understand me so no no
no no no no no when she can understand
what the [ __ ] stand-up comedy is and how
i do it and why i do it right that's
dead if i go to the house and lauren and
uh longest yard is on and my wife's like
look at that egg turn that the [ __ ] off
i don't one time my wife slipped and she
saw it she's like is that you and i'm
like no no and she didn't give a [ __ ]
she goes get that off perfect she don't
give a [ __ ] there's certain things that
i gotta feed her
little by little dog i don't know what
order they're gonna come what day is she
gonna come and go daddy they showed us a
prison today were you ever in prison
come here for a second let me tell you a
little [ __ ] story about your father
all right and you know
what about the dad got to tell about her
20 20 year old sister before her and why
you have no idea how this chapter of
stories is gonna wind up
what about the day she comes up people
go what about youtube what about the day
she comes up to me when she's 12.
and she goes i was watching the video
you and lee
you said you were snorting coke or some
chicks [ __ ] did you ever snuck you know
what i'm saying
this is the [ __ ] that i wake up at two
in the morning and go oh my god
like this i'm one way ahead of you yeah
yeah i'm way ahead of your weather so
you want me to sell her whether it's
good for cancer victims that's the least
of my [ __ ] dilemmas you know saying
that's the least of my [ __ ] dilemmas
okay
right you know i don't want that [ __ ]
weed in the house
so you don't have weed in the house yet
yes i do but i have it on the other side
of the house way away from her
i don't let my wife leave in the yard if
i go out there i wait till she's in the
bedroom and i go out to a certain thing
and i smoke out there
i keep the weeds smoking in the backyard
to unlimited
just for right now just for [ __ ]
right now yeah she's young still no no
but you also accomplish a [ __ ] ton for
somebody that's like the whole you know
this is why my wife
rushed to back down on it rest of
america thought that like anybody else
that somebody who smokes marijuana is
lazy right it's a gateway to other drugs
and they also think that they just sit
around and play video games right and
they're like humbly anti everything
right that smokes marijuana marijuana
they're not the only one either
marijuana to me is a stimulant
put some coffee with that that's another
stimulant they're mixing those now you
know
a piece of nicotine gum
that puts you over the top you
understand me you can get like fancy
coffee with you know yeah it's 35
million don't get a dick for nobody i
gotta sit there and drink ten cups of
coffee and be high and piss like a
[ __ ] savage now for eight hours
yeah you're you do break the stereotype
that's what i hope with my kids no
that's the thing right to me since i was
13 and i didn't know how to describe it
for me from the time i started smoking
weed forget about work ethic
what marijuana did like if you had a
hard job you called uncle joey i would
go i'd assess it
and i'd say ceiling it's gonna cost you
a yardstick
and i would smoke a little bit and go
back in that room
and put music on and i wouldn't stop for
four hours
and then for four hours i'd come out
again i'd take another two salutes
go back in there get a half and cheese
sandwich
that was my thing
i would work i'd do anything
but i had to be high
as long as i was high i could [ __ ] do
whatever the [ __ ] you had for me give me
a minute to figure it the [ __ ] out but
mule work
there was nobody better i did more mule
work high i could paint rooms
if you come to me and say i got a
building i got five rooms that are
exactly the same
the first room is gonna be hard because
now by the time i get to the second one
it's gonna be easy i go in there and
mask everything up i throw paint
i think what do you think gives you the
patience to do that type of [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] six years but i feel like
that's the same thing as parenting like
it gives you the patience to parent let
me okay it's like you said the running
around
saturday mornings
saturday [ __ ] mornings
i wake up at 7am the girls are sleeping
until 8 30. my wife wakes up about 7 15
i wake up about maybe 30 minutes 45
minutes before my wife i wake up i press
the coffee thing
i clean up some [ __ ] cat vomit and
[ __ ]
i go to my room i put the candle on i
pee
i wash my hands i put on the computer i
open up the three [ __ ] places i'm
gonna go to
i start checking hotmails i drink some
coffee after a couple after like three
or four sips of coffee it's on sailing i
go out to my backyard whether it's 6 15
whether it's dark out still i fill up
that [ __ ] pipe i close both doors
behind me and i hit that [ __ ] thing
if i got some impulso i hit it again
like a savage i go in there and i drink
some more coffee with some [ __ ]
nicotine gum and it's all over i start
writing goals
i [ __ ] send my emails out by that
time i hear my wife
i hear my wife in the kitchen [ __ ]
throwing garbage out of doing [ __ ]
something yelling at one of the cats or
some [ __ ]
and
i've already done
an hour's worth of work
in 30 minutes i'm already alive i
already know my mission for the day
i know exactly how i feel if i'm gonna
go to jiu jitsu or not or i got a plan b
i mean i but this is the way i've always
been on it
yeah like i don't think you're alone
there i think a lot of people are like
that but the stereotype stereotypes
you're like a lazy [ __ ] and you know
you can't take care of your kids and
stuff and that's why when you know when
the yahoo thing came out people were
like well she's clearly an uneducated
lazy you know [ __ ] and she's going to
lose her kids and you know what i i have
two businesses on my own i have my life
coaching practice and the blog and uh
and then i work for um i freelance and
do like radio work for freelance stuff
and i freelance right for other places
as well
and like i don't know my kids see me
working i work around the clock i never
stop and i have you know a master's
degree and a bunch of certifications and
a trained rehab counselor like i'm not
talking out of my ass and yet people
here's a stereotype
celia that why is it
like that your next blog is a picture
you um with a glass of wine right or a
picture you with a joint yeah why not i
could get away with what do you
accept me i'm 300 [ __ ] pounds i drink
two glasses of wine you can do whatever
you want you can stick cucumbers up my
[ __ ]
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want i
don't even have a [ __ ] but after you
drink your glasses of wine i got to put
you understand
i get [ __ ] i'm stealing that i guess
brilliant i get [ __ ] up you know i'm
not an alcoholic dude there's a heineken
in there you want to drink it both of us
will be on our [ __ ] asses yeah last
time i drank a heineken out here i was
[ __ ] up and thirsty it's like eating a
pork sandwich
holy [ __ ] eat a pork sandwich at 6 30 at
night and go to bed you'll wake up at
three [ __ ] dimes i don't want to do
that but uh
yeah i don't i drink i mean i usually
drink on the weekends and when i say a
drink i have like a drink or a few beers
on a saturday if i'm out but uh i don't
i don't typically drink and i don't
drink during on school nights like we
say in my house i don't drink on school
nights i don't feel like i can get up i
practice yoga for an hour and a half
every day and if i drink and i wake up
the next morning i feel like crap but if
i smoke
i mean you're healthy
but yeah you're but you're i hear what
you're saying it's the it's the
stereotype moms can have wine and we can
have i'll give me all the wine you know
and like you said moms aren't allowed to
have fun
california just get voted into marijuana
didn't they reject it two times
yeah uh
one time once
think about that they got rejected one
but we can drink got rejected in [ __ ]
florida didn't no it passed this time
the president just passed they could
protect the ones but
people wanted people are not ready for
it you know how they got anything so
this is so much worse for you tax money
tax money well yeah i mean tax money
that's how they sold california well and
big pharma is gonna be involved soon
yeah but i don't even [ __ ] think
about that [ __ ] that's always let me
tell you what the sad thing is that if
you drive i i always like i said to you
i don't mind if you sell weight in my
life
i always know you're gonna sell it
just do it professionally
i
love to go to my weed store i'm a very
loyal [ __ ] dude lee knows i [ __ ]
get pissed of him when he [ __ ] yelps
and goes to different stupid places
but you'll try this they can only get
cute with me you know what i'm saying
people see those canisters and they see
the name on there so when i go to your
store treat me a little [ __ ] nice you
know what i'm saying there's places that
treat me really [ __ ] nice
so last week i went to this other weed
store i saw it i was driving in fact i
was with my wife
we're going to get lunch and i go you
know what honey i'm going to go there
with
she don't give a [ __ ]
i just say it though she looks and this
is great
it just listens to the music so the next
morning i went in there oh my god
me i'm sitting there going this place
i'm not even a realtor
see i'm not a realtor
but i know what twenty thousand a month
is
on ventura boulevard in studio city sure
with four parking spots
in front of your store for that two four
you understand me four four four i'm
ventura boulevard right in the heart of
studios that's 29 yeah that's twenty
thousand the [ __ ] month
they got two employees that look like
[ __ ] models of course the chick had a
rack with a low-cut t-shirt of course
and the guy was trying to be a guy but i
knew he had sucked a couple [ __ ]
somewhere along the line the security
guard was there you know
my point is that i think these places
are getting a little bit too big for
their britches they've gotten awfully
fast you go to hollywood
you really go
wow oh you must really like love the
whole budtender concept then no no no no
no no
yeah
the first wheat store ever went to was
next to the dukes on sunset boulevard
the guy knew me from the comedy street
sergeant eddie griffin and he just came
in when they go so what's up daughter
nothing goes what are you doing here
breakfast what are you doing here
because i own the weed store come on
over and give me a holler
and i went in and they had a hot little
black chick from the bronx with the
[ __ ] accent when the boogie down and
[ __ ]
quit like the whole oh my god and she
was killing [ __ ] because she
was back there smoking
and selling and passing you a joint
[ __ ] by anything they didn't
know what the [ __ ] was going on she was
tremendous you know
but some of these people have lost their
minds they used to be a place on
formosa
formosa and santa barbara santa monica
in hollywood this is ten years ago
they had a guy out in the street and he
checked your security in fact i saw
lawrence fishburne outside there one day
he wasn't going into by weed i was
standing out there and he just said the
lord i said hello to him
but i used to go in there and i'll never
forget one day i went in there
straight face hollywood 2009
and the girl goes hi welcome to whatever
the place was and i had been there about
four times already
and i thought they had a sense of humor
when i looked like oh me answers them
she was what are you looking for is it
to you
you know
and i look like a listen
i want to see the [ __ ] devil
but she just looked at me and she goes
we don't use the type of language
[Laughter]
listen to me we're living in a place
that tomorrow morning if you'd like
i think my wife has yoga at 10 30.
you're more than welcome to come to the
house we will take you to breakfast and
after breakfast
i'm gonna take you to colfax
and
ventura
close your eyes you know what that is i
do there's a jinky's breakfast place
there okay
we're gonna park the car by the
weightlifting place and we'll walk down
the stairs
and you walk down there there's a little
running path
and we're going to take a joint one of
the joints you brought me today from the
farm
i'm going to take that joint we're going
to spark it
and
2017 studio city california
lee's gonna sit there with a clicker
and we're gonna smoke the whole joint
and we're gonna watch
how many people are gonna hold their
noses and give us dirty looks
you will look at me and go joking i
thought you were [ __ ] lying to me i'm
gonna go this is why
you can't say this type of [ __ ] about
marijuana you want to smoke your weed
you got to keep it under the hat because
these people are still living
in nineteen twenty they hold their nose
and walk by you i've never seen that
here really
it's crowded i'll take you to a point
i'm totally i'm i will take you to a
place
that you'll see like grandma's running
by your grandmas you'll have your
[ __ ] joint and [ __ ] they were born in
like 1930.
and you'll see them running and also now
look at your goal and they'll hold their
noses
and they'll run past you and once they
get 20 yards from you they'll look back
and give you a dirty list they'll take
pictures of you can i wear my mama
t-shirt just
yeah bring a video camera yeah you will
die you will go joey i thought you were
kidding me this is why are you
intimidating grandma thank you
they could be listening they could be 40
year old moms i just went down there one
day
one day i said let me go for a walk i
put my running sneakers on
and i just got caught up down there
you're all right and i took a [ __ ] no
i don't know how you get to this
situation and i took a joiner and i
sparked it down there about 9 15 in the
morning
and people were running by and they were
pissed off at me if six people went by
four of them after actually turned
around and just stared at me for like
five minutes like
how could you you know there's this like
those are the same people though that
when they're running on the treadmill
they fart next to the person like that's
running next to them and don't care
so you know you know they're just
[ __ ] we live in a place where uh
they're ready but they're not ready they
don't i we can't reach them from any
level like
you know you finally believe in
something when
you know what man i have a child and
celia's child had a problem and uh cbd
are all cured them
now we relate we have something to
relate on wow really so i'll bump into
your swim class
she looks great cb deal
that's what you're telling me celia you
jewish aren't you
you're trying to [ __ ] look me in the
face and talk to him i see me dealing
with everything you people have [ __ ]
been through you gonna talk to me about
[ __ ] cbd all about everything they
went
yeah we didn't really kill jesus you
know i mean
you know you think about it and you
but it really does work for people okay
you're working for my wife yeah she sees
it because of that
she came to me and then she goes i don't
know what happened the other night i
sprayed it i lost count
and i don't know how high i got whatever
she goes it's empty
i mean she goes make sure you go today i
mean she was serious yeah she said that
morning the first thing i went and got a
cb deal i'd put on an account let me
tell you something i could put a [ __ ]
thing on that counter a month later that
thing will be on that [ __ ] counter i
put that box in the counter she swooped
it up like that and took it to her
bedroom i worked my wife slowly
she's not gonna get high the highest
she's gonna get is on that juice
at 11 15 at night that's as high as she
gets when i walk in there
she's not snoring no more she's not
biting her mouth peace no more her sleep
anxiety has gone away now
would somebody believe me in
in
america if i told them this no they
don't i have no validation for them to
believe me yeah but they should believe
you more than other people you are a
naysayer anyway and you use the stuff
here's the beauty like you're the best
person you listen to about no no like
when what's a guy did that did it on cnn
what's that do super oh uh gupta
somebody was against marijuana until
they saw that
sanjay sanjay thing and then they put it
on a bill to vote into
you know that's how
influential
that's the type of people that have to
influence marijuana it's not fat [ __ ]
ex-felons like me
or a little chubby jewish it is moms
though
moms is a a part of the circle
to influence yeah when mom say something
is okay listen to me
i don't think
a lot of people in america are ready to
blow
[ __ ] reefer smoke in their kids faces
who's blowing reversals
yes of course i think you have a legit
story for viceland
i think you yeah i really do yeah uh
i i agree i would love to do that
they're actually they um
i've talked to vice lamb before and
actually and i think i'm pretty pro uh
pro marijuana but um they
last i knew they were looking for a mom
pregnant to to smoke while pregnant on
camera and even that i can't get behind
like if i i can't that to me is uh
pushing it a little bit for me
and that's saying something but i you
know listen i think like we were talking
about in the beginning with you know
duis like it was moms that changed that
uh you know
outlook and that's what was mad that got
behind making sure that we had duis moms
really can change things if you think
about like a lot of movements gay rights
movement you know it was moms that came
out and they're like i accept my gay son
and then you know what that changed
pretty fast lots of people were a lot
more accepting once mom said it was okay
two things real quick
please another question i dread
daddy why are those two dudes holding
hands
you wouldn't lean on hold hands ah
we do you guys aren't here no we don't
plead
okay we don't [ __ ] hold hands
when again when gay marriage got put
that came way before my daughter was
born and the first people i thought of
were parents that picked their kids up
at the park and two guys are making out
in the corner and your son that's
five looks you in the eye and goes dad
why are those guys over there swapping
spit
feeling each other i don't like pda so i
don't see anybody make out but my that
my i exposed my kids to that early too
listen listen
gay couples would would babysit for my
kids yeah no no no no i had i my mom had
the ball we had gay people in there
again i'm not saying nothing bad oh what
i'm saying is that
in my mind there's people in middle
america
yeah that if your son comes home and
says that to you go home and get a
shotgun yo i'm sure
i'm pretty sure they left the comments
on yeah what are you saying right you
know what i'm saying i just saw two guys
at the park
making out with cowboy hats on
like that movie yeah brought back that
one broke back mountain also that father
go home and get a shout out yeah they
don't even think about that [ __ ] you
know there's people that are ready for
this and there's people that aren't
ready we can sit here
and talk stupid arguments that have been
beat up
like a [ __ ] carpet
they've been beat like a [ __ ] carpet
but we've
bought into it because we've seen it
right we've seen the changes it's done
right
if you think when i started smoking dope
at 13
and going to shop right and stealing a
six pack of hubba bubba and going back
to school and throwing hubba bubba at
each other
that i amounted that someday
myself and another woman
that has a mummy's website i'm going to
be here
talking about marijuana and the
knowledge i learned
from that early education as stupid as
it sounds
because
i grew up in the 70s when
they weren't really looking at adhd
and all these child symptoms that they
look at today
do i believe in all these things no
no i believe that you know the same
feelings you had
when you had that postpartum they
started putting drugs into you yeah and
these drugs
you would like to sit here to a green in
the face we both know that bad for you
yep it causes a chemical imbalance in
your [ __ ] body and your [ __ ] brain
i mean a lot of them are some of them
are very helpful for certain times but
not when you start eating 12 of them
honey no
no into your little skinny [ __ ] frame
and your mind and your husband you have
a child i was nursing my kid i don't
know what that did to her you just said
you had a weird emotion totally you know
these are all things that you know i
remember going to my doctor once again i
needed an anxiety pill he didn't give me
xanax he gave me this other thing and as
funny as the story is i took it
i'm like that's the weirdest [ __ ]
pill
i've ever taken a month away but i had
this friend like a zoloft or something
it was crazy i don't know nothing about
zoloft
this [ __ ] was off the chains crazy a
couple weeks before that a friend of
mine said i have an oxycontin you would
do what i'm saying no no i didn't he
goes i'm going to give you a tiny amount
of 16th of a 16th of a 16th it was just
a little chip i'm at home one night i
got a spot at 10 30. i popped this thing
at like 7 30 i'm sitting there [ __ ]
eight o'clock lee i'm sweating
profusiously like that night i passed
out in here from telling you the bloody
story i started sweating profusely i
take my shirt off and [ __ ] the room
started spinning out of camps on my spot
and go to bed i never ate something
so bad but the next morning you know
what i didn't remember
the [ __ ] synthetic feeling that i had
yes
in that morning
and then i went on those anxiety pills
and i started getting the same feeling
and i had this friend sergio love that
did every anything remember those
uh chex commercials when we were kids
what is it checks give it to mikey mikey
life life
it wasn't like life
life life is like one of my favorites me
too
mikey likes it i like life
so
sergio you can give them anything so one
night surgery you should celebrate
surgical sergio take these pills let me
know what you think the heavy duty
he called me two days later he was what
the [ __ ] were those things and i threw
the rest of them away and i started
anytime i got a little bit of anxiety i
started smoking weed yep
at that time i started putting it
together
weed stores were opening i finally went
and got my license uh so i'm gonna quit
smoking i'm gonna do this this this is
and marilyn was gonna help me do all
those things and it did
yep no i agree
and today i could look sit here and say
this
i never went to a psych as a kid god
knows i should death of my mom the death
of my dad
at an early age that's gotta be
traumatizing yeah
you know
but i gotta tell you something
i think a lot of the years would kept me
together
and what gave me hope sometimes is when
you smoke and you get that wind of
creativity
that's also a win to thought if you
don't have a notebook
and sometimes that thought will pick you
up from a dark spot
because i know it did me guys i know for
a fact what it did to me
you know all those years i was in dark
places prisoner
when i got locked up they put me on
something
at first i wanted it to get high
but i tried to like four or five times
i'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] they give to gorillas to
calm down and shoot after the circus
like a tranquilizer
a dark gun yeah oh my god
and then i started taking them in prison
and some of them played ten bucks and
that guy was smoking him
oh my god he was getting [ __ ] up
it's like this little brown capsule
it's under what's that thing when you do
the shuffle
people do the something shuffle the
morphine shuffle
the something shuffle this is the cousin
to that pill and there was a little
dosage the first night i ate i slept for
like 16 hours
like i woke up but like in the twilight
zone you ever eat one of those and the
next day i took it again i slept right
oh my god why'd you do it again because
let's see what it takes let's see what
this cave takes you that i took it down
again like the third night in prison
and it was okay like that night
and the next one i woke up a little
nausea and i was like i don't know about
this because one night i had eaten
codeine
and uh in boulder colorado i ate some
cody's to come down off of coke [ __ ]
and i had the same nausea feeling the
next morning
so that night when they gave it to you
again at seven o'clock
i said should i take it i [ __ ] took
it
and that night i got kind of high
and i go you know what how many nights
am i and i asked my buddy what it was
because you don't want to keep taking
that [ __ ] that's just going to make you
a dead dick
you know it's going to [ __ ] up your mind
you don't want to keep taking that i go
you know what it's not worth it but he
goes i know he'll [ __ ] take those
from you and he'll give you a high
dollar this crazy white dude
so i wait for the [ __ ] doctor to come
i may believe i put it in my lip
once they leave i pop it out of my lip
and i bring it to my buddy and he'd give
me like 750 eight dollars whatever the
market price was and that was the end of
that
he'd crush it up and smoke those things
we have a huge problem with that stuff
in this country huge
opiates are
that's a big deal
well i'll tell you what where legal
marijuana states with marijuana illegal
opiate emergency use
emergency room visits are lower i read
this thing the other day yeah and it
makes sense it makes sense to a guy like
me but most people wouldn't understand
that guy
they look at it as uh
the devil they look at it but you know
they started using uh marijuana to help
patients in rehab come off of opiates
like they're using it now as treatment
it's been all the because i'm you know
rehab counselor so i i like stay on
those threads and i think that's really
fascinating and it doesn't surprise me
at all either because it levels you out
like we've said it levels you out like
if you have any sort of imbalance it
really can i got xanax at the house
right i could eat as alice
i don't know how you do it i could take
two or three stars
and there's really no difference i'm
looking at you [ __ ] straight in the
face
and telling you go home and take your
xanax or your value
and you're gonna wake up tomorrow a
little groggy yeah hangover i'm gonna
give i'm gonna give you a start you're
gonna when you go home tonight you're
gonna take a bite of it you're gonna go
like this tonight time to look when the
kids go out of the [ __ ] house
you're gonna go my uncle joey gave me
something you girls can't sleep here
go to your [ __ ] go to your [ __ ]
father's house i'll do it this
weekend and you take the first time okay
let's assume this is 125 correctly yes
this is one that's right so if i cut it
in half
it's 65
62 all right so if i like ate the corner
so you ate the corn on one of these
huh
that's 35 milligrams right i guarantee
the next day xanax you call me up and go
joey
won't you go on 60 minutes and talk
about this again i think nobody would
believe me i need five world-class
doctors
to go on television
and overthrow
the [ __ ] uh
anna what's the adam well it's you know
it's like it's oh uh ativan
what are you sleepings aren't there
three big ones can you imagine if well
the five doctors went on national tv and
said listen people
you could go to your pharmacy right now
and take ambien or whatever the [ __ ] it
is
or
you could buy these right here and take
a little bite off no they're not going
to say that because they don't make any
money on them
so you're always going to lose that war
which is a money war yeah that's the war
you lose which is but it doesn't matter
because you're winning your personal
wait do you know do you know what the
organization uh can of kids is have you
ever seen anything about them oh my god
i hang out with them all the time no i
don't [ __ ] know these people
can of kids is a mom a mom started
another mom started a whole like thing
she's working with all kinds of doctors
and doing tests and stuff with kids with
cancer using cannabis
oh my god i'm going deep it's i'm deep
in them
you can't be deep enough listen to me
lee eight
four two
he hit like six he's on at six oh he
said six stars no no i started i started
five all right what do you got i'm he
gave me two all right and then he gave
me two from the nine one more no
oh my god i'm gonna leave in ten i just
played ten
i just think i did not lee i've been
eating stars here two of the [ __ ]
shots i'm doing what live form okay i
gave you another star with the tea the
chocolate too dude that's what i'm
saying i gave you the star with the thc
finger on it and [ __ ]
one of the dogs but listen they give
they give kids all these like crappy
medications to fight cancer but they've
like held back on this don't you think
that's messed up and if you saw research
being done and you and you buy it in
that like and that's the other thing
listen you already talked about this you
know as far as like medi you know we
showed that or we've talked about you
know cancer being helped by
uh by weed so like how why is it so like
not that you're disagreeing but the
people that have come at me about it
it's like if it might actually cure
cancer and it helps people feel better
from [ __ ] cancer is it really that
hard to wrap your head around the fact
that it helps me feel better you know
with anxiety and [ __ ] postpartum
depression because i don't think that
that's like anything as you know next to
[ __ ] cancer and yet this is stuff
that we have to like argue with about
you know with moms not you but other
people
but you're seeing the light you know
who gives a [ __ ] you're all right you're
healthy
we're gonna put the kiss of death on
yourself you know what i'm saying yes
let me read some responses and we'll get
the [ __ ] out of him we'll wrap it up
i'm happy you came on i am too thank you
i want people to go to little mamas i
want people to follow you thank you i
think you're very interesting i think
that uh i get where the [ __ ] you're
coming from thank you just that uh
you went on a liberal mom web page on an
election year
you know with all the [ __ ] that's
going on
and you just crash their heads and it's
like if i what you did to people was
pull the plug out in las vegas
las vegas would sit and go what happened
to electricity [ __ ] uh celia
pulled the [ __ ] plug
we also just endorsed a cannabis farm
which was a big deal for a mob to do
people are not ready people are becoming
believers one by one again you don't see
me jumping up and down like john
mcdougall
but i'm telling you that i see it in
different people kids came from new york
just as big as i am went to jiu jitsu
went there for a whole week
i became friends with my oh really
you're from long island goes yeah
he goes i quit my [ __ ] job
and i went to san diego and i [ __ ]
worked out six days a week and it's been
great i go you're a big guy six days a
week and he goes man i came out here and
discovered cbdo
and he goes i'm not a sore anymore like
a workout he goes in fact i bought a
bunch of bottles to take back to new
york with me
you know i know that when
i gave up
edibles for lent this year
and it helped my reefer but the cbd all
felt a lot better also
in fact if i spray three or four sprays
at night at cbdo i get a little [ __ ]
up at night i'm not gonna land nobody i
mean i don't see the devil i don't wanna
you know [ __ ] jump out the window but
i feel a little wheezy i gotta go to
sleep if i wake up in the middle of
night i'm gonna have insomnia i go in
the computer room i put the youtube on
with music i put a notebook out i
sprayed three or four of those cb deals
i smoke a little bit
give it an hour i can't believe you can
do all that but dabs turn you off like
you're not i don't want that [ __ ] in my
house listen up do it in here listen
listen no no no this is my office i'm
not gonna get my [ __ ] car and come
all the way over here to get i no no no
like i talked to
i'm a really
traditional type dude
you know
i know i kind of love that we argue
about this once i got a
once i can't roll it once i can i don't
want to be involved with
that blowtorch oh yeah
that [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out
it is scary
it makes my wife think about things you
don't need to [ __ ] think about it i
hear that kabeesh yeah my life is
dedicated to my wife so there's no drunk
because if you have a happy wife you
have a happiness you've got a happy life
you keep them happy they don't see blow
torches in your [ __ ] kitchen
you know it doesn't it does really
ridiculous oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i don't
need my wife
no my wife does me something that she
does for me because she loves me
because she knows that i'll [ __ ] it up
if i do it
but once every two weeks i look at my
wife
i give her my pipe
and my wife looks at me i go thank you
she does something with it
an hour later it's in my bathroom
spotless on top of a paper towel
i'll see you an hour later thanks for
the appartment you go yeah
and that's it that's the only thing
she'll do for your life yes no no no no
my wife is cool as [ __ ] she really is i
for me to keep that i can't show up in
my house
with six [ __ ]
with a blowtorch and bring them in my
yard for no reason no yeah okay
no that don't even it's fair that
doesn't even come close to my world like
my wife doesn't i i for the record and
before people send me hate mail i don't
have a blow torch or anything like that
in my house either whatever the [ __ ]
they show up with the rocks and this
thing okay listen if you gotta take more
than the bong that i gave you tonight
you need heroin why [ __ ] around with a
rock right why are you [ __ ] around
you're trying to
listen
i don't [ __ ] around if you show up to
the [ __ ] cause of voodoo
or we shoot this [ __ ] playset and i
have reefer here it's [ __ ]
world-class briefly i have to come see
you live now i'm happy you came on i am
celia [ __ ] bihar aka bayhard
aka over at little mamas.com and [ __ ]
[ __ ] putting it together for you
again don't forget
i'm going to talk to you people about
something father's day is coming you
know i was joking around and [ __ ] about
your father's [ __ ] before
i don't know if your father's [ __ ]
smells i'm just using particulars i'm 54
from finding the time to time
i scratch my anus in the middle of the
day and i sniff it because i'm curious
and i know it's got some wang to it
and i immediately go to the [ __ ] uh
hello tushy and i wash my [ __ ] and i
even bust out soap sometimes and put the
[ __ ]
towel in there and mix it all up and get
the brown eye clean
you're ready to go you're confident
about your [ __ ] you want your dad to
be confident
hellotushy.com the bidet is back okay
you don't know what a [ __ ] bidet is
let me tell you what bidet is
but there's a is a device that washes
your little muffler clean after you go
to the bathroom
right there now to install one will be
thousands of dollars you don't need that
hellotushy.com is a new
portable
uh
bidet that you install right it goes
right into your toilet
boom so after you take the staminkia or
after ladies after you get a little
stabbing and he shoots that little
[ __ ] techno glue in your monkey you
know what i'm saying
you get that love plasma and that
[ __ ] skunk of yours
you went out three nights this week and
got three different [ __ ] what do you
think that hoe smells like you think
that's a that's a pleasantry for anybody
thank god this last guy had a bidet you
could just crack that cricket
put that water in it throw some soap in
that [ __ ] and ping ping poom
your monkeys back and [ __ ] anyway
whether it's a muffler whether it's your
monkey
whether it's your helmet hello tushy
does it all you understand me but they
focus on the muffler move the whole
thing why because that's where diseases
start that's when you get hemorrhoids
and you get different itches
and different diseases
you get [ __ ] crab breath what is that
crap what is that crab crotch
when people are sitting there and
they're scratching their ass whatever
crab scratch whatever the [ __ ] it's
called you get that from sitting in your
office all day never again
it's a portable device you go home you
sit on that thing you don't have time
for a shower you [ __ ] put the cold
water right in your little muffler oh my
god you don't know what peace
and serenity is
until you have a little water hitting
your little muffler in the afternoon
after a long stressful day at the office
or wherever you've been hello tishi is
guaranteed for 90 day guarantee
nothing will happen and they ship right
to your house do me a favor go to
hellotushy.com
look at the portable bidet you're gonna
fall in love you're gonna fall in love
okay you're not gonna buy one of them
you're gonna buy two of them one for
your dad and one for your mom because
their asshole's been looking like it got
some wang to it from time to time you
know what i'm saying she's eating those
biscotts again and
[ __ ] backs up in that little muffler
anyway you can buy one for the office
buy for the office go to hellotushy.com
right now and present
what is it
boom helloturgy.com get 10 off you're
new hello tushy never have a stinky
[ __ ] again
number two
are you hiring do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidates no
you don't
let me explain something to you it's
very hard in today's market the great to
get great you know great prospects for
whatever position you're looking for
if you're sick and tired of going
through a resume
zip recruit is for you with ziprecruiter
you can post your job to a hundred plus
job sites with one click then that
powerful technology efficiently matches
the right people to your job better than
anybody else that's why zip recruiter is
different
unlike other job sites ziprecruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them in fact over 80 percent of
jobs posted on zip recruiter get a
qualified candidate in just 24 hours can
you beat that no you can't no juggling
emails no calls to your office nobody
showing up at your office with a suit
you know with a resume
that those days are over simply screen
rate and manage the candidates all in
one place with zip recruiters easy to
use dashboard
do me a favor find out today why
ziprecruiter has been used by businesses
of all sizes to find the most qualified
job candidates with immediate results
and right now today my listeners can
post jobs on ziprecruiter for free
gratis free that's right free just go to
ziprecruiter.com slash church
and post your jobs for free that's
ziprecruiter.com
church one more time go to free go to
ziprecruiter.com
slash church this is the this is what
you've been waiting for
number two i want to introduce the new
product that
i love i personally fell in love with it
i spoke to uh
one of the people involved with the
company we had a nice phone conversation
and i listened to what he had to say and
his mission was beautiful
i mean
looking good doesn't need to cost you a
fortune
5-4 club is revolutionizing the way men
shop
each month they send you a curated box
of two to three items for the hand picks
to match the current season and your
style hand-picked they've been helping
men with fashion for over 15 years and
they ship to over a hundred thousand men
every month they know what they're doing
so if you don't that's okay five four
club will help you build your wardrobe
one month at a time
you're sitting there wearing clothes in
1980 like your uncle joey you don't need
that stuff you want to be hip you want
to be modern
you want to know people that you're
making a statement because when you look
good you feel good it's just a fact of
life what happens is this you get 100
120 worth of clothes for just 60 dollars
a month
you can pause or cancel any time no
commitment and as a 5-4 club member you
also receive
50 off items in their online shop and
access to exclusive members only items
free shipping and
size exchange
all right do me a favor go to
fivefourclub.com right now and at the
promo code joey and they'll give you 50
off your first month's package plus a
free pair of sunglasses who's better
than you
that's fifty percent off your first
package at five four club spell five f i
v e
f o u r club club.com promo code joey
let me explain something to you
this is the way to go
120 hours worth of clothes every month
for 60
delivered right to your house and if you
do it right now they're gonna throw in
50 off your first month's package plus a
free pair of sunglasses chris paul mark
wahlberg they use the 5-4 club the 5-4
club is featured in gq vice and in style
with over 15 years of experience
it's safe to say that the 5'4 club
stylists are experts all right do
yourself a favor again go to the 5-4
club right now and at the promo code
joey they're going to give you 50 off
your first month package plus a free
pair of sunglasses who's better than you
that's how we're ending the month i want
to thank
hellotushy.com i want to thank the 5 4
group and i want to thank zip recruiter
for sponsoring the podcast tonight i
love you [ __ ] don't forget
thursday night flap is 7 30.
i'm doing a workout 10 bucks a a
notebook full of [ __ ] that comes in my
mind when i smoke 52 joints and also
next thursday brilliant improv [ __ ]
bring it with his whole madness started
thursday night friday night two shows
saturday we're coming at you like a
[ __ ] uh
big black kahuna you understand me
anyway i want to thank my girl gina baja
tell them the name of the web page again
gina celia
it's been a lot of joints no no no you
look like gina from miami vice so i'll
take that chick from where we were it's
the lil mamas.com mommy yeah she's got a
great blog
as you can tell she got balls of steel i
love her
you know she's making a statement ladies
get on the [ __ ] program wash your
[ __ ] get hello tushy and that's it i
love your [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah all right wash your [ __ ]
use hello tushy who's better than uncle
joey
thank you for having me
hit it
mother do lee think
you